alle schon am start hier go wizard ist am start bei es auch dann spiele ich
das trinken erst mal du meinst sie jetzt videos generieren kann ja habe ich schon
gehört und das ist das erste mal wo ich so denke da hätte ich theoretischen anwendungszweck für
mich weil ich habe manchmal keine ahnung was ich den hintergrund packen soll ja ich
meine zu bestellen bestimmten sachen man einen screenshot von irgendwas wo man halt sieht dass
das wirklich so ist aber ich kann ja keinen 15 minuten beitrag wie im fernsehen machen oder so
ja also dafür wäre schon echt ganz nice dass man vielleicht ein bisschen passenden hintergrund
kram generieren kann ansonsten zeige ich euch halt irgendwelchen anderen kram
irgendwie wo im terminal ist was passiert oder keine ahnung irgendwie aus irgendeinem game wo
nicht so viel aufmerksamkeit braucht aber ja also das wird tatsächlich echt richtig richtig gut wenn
das gescheit funktioniert ja übrigens ist ja was nicht gescheit funktioniert youtube hat einfach
meine watch history resettet ein paar sachen hat es gecheckt weil ich vorher ein paar videos
gemacht habe aber das ist das eigene sache wie es jetzt eigentlich aufgebrochen ist und immer wieder
an die art mit dem opel und ich dachte naja ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt so ein bisschen
richtig so das ist ja so da war auch die sache eine leute die sich eigentlich nicht zufrieden
hat mit dem opel aber die waren so hoch als es Greg formal gesagt haben und den mann aber
die leute sie sich jetzt immer gerne daran bewirkt dass das hier eineاتas oder das ist ein tolles
spiel für euch und ich hoffe dass es euch auch gut gefällt wenn ich in den kommentaren kommentiert habe
dann würde ich mich gerne an euch schicken wenn ihr noch gar nichts mehrostens sagen möchtet dann
schreibt mir wieder in die kommentare und wir sehen uns dann auf der nächsten time auf der nächsten time auf der additional
Und meinst du, ich sehe nicht, dass man das sein innen kann, oder was?
Gleich, wenn ihr so weitermacht, mache ich euch Weep-Musik an für fünf Minuten.
Dann ist es vorbei.
Nee, nee.
Nee, nee, das ist, das liegt nicht daran, dass mein Cookie ausläuft.
Das liegt daran, dass YouTube irgendwas von mir wissen wollte.
Das habe ich beantwortet und seitdem ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen das wieder weg.
So ein paar Sachen hat es schon gecheckt, weil ich wieder aufgemacht habe, aber es ist halt Schrott.
War die Woche irgendwas Wichtiges?
Habe ich irgendwas Spannendes verpasst?
Ich habe mitbekommen, es gab irgendeine Sicherheitslücke in...
Nee, Docker war letzte Woche, gell?
Docker war letzte Woche.
Es gab irgendwas in...
Anders.
Ach, im Ausweis.
Äh, im, im...
Ja, Postgres, Postgres auch.
Nee, es war doch irgendwas, habe ich gelesen, mit der...
Mit irgendwelchen Apps, die auf die elektronische ID vom...
Ausweis zugreifen können.
Habe ich irgendwo gesehen.
Guck mal.
Wobei ich das, wobei ich das auch nur am...
Ja, gut, keine Ahnung.
Wobei ich das auch nur am Rande gecheckt habe, weil da geht es ja darum, dass die Leute Zugriffs auf Smartphone brauchen
und dort irgendwelche manipulierten Apps installieren müssen und sowas.
Und da weiß ich nicht wirklich, ob das so eine, wie soll man sagen, eine richtige Sicherheitslücke ist, wenn...
Also in der Größe, wie es gemacht... Ich weiß es nicht.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, wie das ist?
Hat eigentlich jeder Ausweis eine elektronische ID mittlerweile oder nicht?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob mein Ausweis das hat.
Ich habe das noch nie verwendet.
Und nachdem ich absolut null Vertrauen in die IT-Projekte unserer Regierung habe,
ähm, beziehungsweise man ja...
Warte mal, wo muss ich jetzt hin?
Das da.
Äh, genau.
Nachdem ich absolut null Vertrauen in die IT-Projekte unserer Regierung habe
und man das die letzten Jahre auch gesehen hat,
geschweige denn,
wie am Anfang von Corona noch die ganzen Daten immer per Fax geschickt werden,
mussten, weil sonst keiner hingekriegt hat,
schafft das auch nicht gerade mehr Vertrauen.
Deswegen werde ich diese Funktion auch nie verwenden.
Ja, das dürfte jeder Ausweis haben.
Ich benutze nicht.
Mein Ausweis liegt irgendwo rum.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo der gerade ist.
Den suche ich immer, wenn ich es mal brauche.
Ich mach mal kurz Package-Update.
Weit weg von allen möglichen Geräten, die da irgendwas senden und empfangen können.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass es alle neue Ausweise haben.
So.
Jetzt.
Outlook New.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Eigentlich, warum habe ich das überhaupt installiert?
Ich benutze den Kram nicht.
Naja.
Lassen wir erstmal Package-Updates machen,
weil, achtsch, by the way.
In der Gezwischenzeit,
wir hatten doch noch ein paar offene Stellenanzeigen,
die wir uns angucken mussten.
Einmal das hier.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen aufräumen.
Was ist das?
Ah, das ist mein Projekt.
Das hat tatsächlich noch Pull-Requests und Issues.
Alles natürlich.
Äh, Skill-Issues der Anwender, logischerweise.
Ach ja, gibt das Fahrräder wieder für mich?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Ich gucke gerade mal kurz, wie es aussieht.
Naja, das kann auch im Sale sein.
Ist mir ehrlich gesagt vollkommen wurscht.
Hauptsache, es gibt wieder was.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Nicht in meiner Größe.
Nicht in meiner Größe, nicht in meiner Grö-
Ah, fuck it.
Schade, ne?
Das ist...
Ja, ich weiß, dass es das nicht gibt.
Ich weiß.
Ich gucke aber gerade schon ein bisschen so rum.
Aber es gibt in meiner Größe irgendwie immer nix.
So.
Machen wir hier mal die ganzen Krempel zu.
Okay.
Ich hab mal eine Feezy-Frage.
Gibt es eigentlich Reverse-Proxy für allgemeine Anwendungen, die abhängig der Domain-Routen,
sodass ich sowohl VPN-Example und...
Ja.
Das macht jeder Reverse-Proxy.
Dafür sind die da.
Jetzt verstehe ich das Problem nicht.
Das macht jeder Reverse-Proxy.
Wo ist das Problem?
Muss es wieder Rose sein?
Cube oder Canon haben aktuell mehr...
Ja, ich weiß.
Also...
Ich fand das Fahrrad sehr bequem.
Also ich hätte gerne wirklich exakt das gleiche Fahrrad wieder.
Plus vielleicht mit einer bisschen aktuelleren Schaltung.
Wozu brauchst du Wireshark?
Also Nginx-Config aus dem Kopf erstellen kann ich auch nicht.
Aber wenn du zum Beispiel sowas wie Cudi nimmst, das ist super simpel zum Erstellen.
Da brauchst du drei Einträge für...
Ach, WireGuard.
Ja gut, WireGuard hat damit auch nix zu tun.
WireGuard ist ja nur wichtig, dass du da hinkommst.
Also das macht jeder Reverse-Proxy.
Das ist ja gerade das...
Beziehungsweise nicht mehr jeder Reverse-Proxy.
Jeder Reverse-Proxy.
Jeder...
Jeder Webserver im Endeffekt kann Virtual Hosts.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Spricht mich auch gar nicht an.
Weil es hat den übelsten Hype gehabt die letzten Jahre über.
Aber ich muss sagen, viele der Spiele-Trends der letzten Jahre gingen eh voll an mir vorbei.
Ich konnte mit der ganzen Battle-Royale-Sache wenig anfangen.
Wenn ich auch das ein oder andere Mal ein bisschen gespielt hab.
Aber...
Ich mein, ich hab sowohl PUBG ein bisschen gespielt, als auch Warzone, als das neue Mal ein bisschen gespielt.
Also richtig krass den Hardcore-Crime da drinnen starten.
Hatte ich keine persönliche Erfahrung.
Hatte ich keine persönliche Motivation.
Naja und...
Hast du jetzt schon etwas mit Coolify gemacht?
Das sagt...
Nee, das sagt mir was.
Das ist irgend so ein...
Entweder ist das irgendeine Low-Code-Plattform.
Oder es ist irgendwie sowas...
Wo du...
Einfach deployen kannst mit irgendeinem Git-Push und dann startet das irgendwie in einen Container mit deiner Anwendung im Hintergrund oder sowas.
Ich weiß es gerade aus dem Kopf nicht.
Aber sowas eins von beiden ist das.
Gell?
Und...
Habe ich jetzt für mich keinen Anwendungszweck bisher gesehen.
Das zweite, ja okay.
Nö.
Ich baue mir einen Docker-File.
Dann habe ich ein Container-Image.
Und das lasse ich laufen.
Brauche ich das andere nicht.
Ist mir alles...
Weiß nicht.
Ich finde, manche Abstraktion muss nicht unbedingt sein.
So, jetzt haben wir hier alles geupdatet.
Lasst mal kurz gucken.
Gibt es hier noch irgendwelche Sachen?
Weil...
Weil Arch, by the way.
Wir brauchen eine neue Package-Version.
Guck mal.
Goland.
Goland?
Guck mal.
Goland gibt es...
Moment.
23.3.4.
Aha.
Da gab es irgendeinen Bug oder so wahrscheinlich.
Weil eigentlich hätte ich ja langsam mal mit 24.01 gerechnet.
Oder mit 24...
1.
Nicht 24.01.
Mit 24.1.
Wann auch immer das endlich rauskommt.
Weil nicht das, was man wirklich brauchen würde.
Das Zeug funktioniert ja auch so wunderbar.
So.
Dann machen wir gleich nochmal Reboot.
Wir müssen uns übrigens auch mal Svelte 5 angucken.
Ich habe da jetzt ein paar Videos zu geguckt.
Das fand ich mega nice, was man da gesehen hat.
Auch wenn die ganzen Leute wieder am Flamen sind.
Oh, es sieht nicht mehr so aus, wie es vorher ausgesehen hat.
Jetzt ist es ganz schlecht.
Ich glaube, dass es unter der Haube besser ist.
Beziehungsweise auch, wenn man sich daran gewöhnt hat, besser ist.
Angular City, das gucke ich mir nicht an.
Nee, auf gar keinen Fall.
So.
Ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen meine Tabs aufräumen.
Wir haben nämlich hier noch ein paar...
Nicht, dass ich jetzt...
Das machen wir jetzt, bevor wir anfangen.
Weil sonst kommen wir da nie dazu.
Vom letzten Stellenanzeigen-Video hatten wir noch ein paar offen.
Die ich mir angucken sollte.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt schnell.
Danach gucken wir uns...
Ah, yes!
Moment, Moment.
Five had wine, Leute.
Exquisite.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, warum ihr das YouTube jetzt empfiehlt, aber...
Gentlemen.
Man of culture.
Alter, 2 Stunden 55.
Ja, ist klar.
Ich trinke mal kurz was.
Yes.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Test Helldivers 2.
Nur ein totaler Bug ist ein guter Bug.
Bug?
Ist das irgendwas mit Starship Troopers?
Zukunftsetting.
Das genau so aussieht.
An dem wir mit dem schweren MG auf dem Boden liegen und uns im Schnee drehen.
Das sieht super aus und sorgt für viel Immersion.
Das Interface erinnert mich ein bisschen an Battlefield.
Ja, Battlefront.
Ja, eher Battlefront.
Du hast recht.
Ja, du hast recht.
Jetzt habe ich einmal so eine Klassik-Musiklist aufgemacht.
Schon denkt YouTube, ja, jetzt möchtest du ganz viel Klassik-Musik hören.
Unbedingt.
Sonst nichts.
Ist das League of Legends?
Ich habe kein Plasma oder ist das Dota?
Ich erkenne das immer vor weitem.
Das ist LOL, oder?
Alter, es ist so schrecklich, wenn YouTube deine Watch-History nicht mehr erkennt.
Was du alles empfohlen kriegst, Mann.
So.
Ich glaube, wir müssen hier mal wieder irgendwie...
Guck mal hier.
Ich gebe dir ein PowerPoint.
Wir müssen irgendwie ein paar Videos aufmachen, die ich noch...
Die ich noch offen hatte.
Dass YouTube wieder lernt, was ich eigentlich gucken will.
Alla, pepega-Kram.
Ja, das liegt daran, weil es meine Watch-History nicht hat.
Mit Watch-History ist das eigentlich ganz, ganz brauchbar.
Ja, so.
Dann machen wir das doch jetzt mal schnell.
Archlinux neu gestartet.
Dann gucken wir uns mal schnell die Stellenanzeigen vom letzten Mal an, was noch übrig geblieben
ist.
Aber wir haben, glaube ich...
LinkedIn.
Wir sollen uns sein innen.
Ich vermute mal, dass die die Stellenanzeige gelöscht haben oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Hatten wir uns das nicht schon angeguckt?
ServiceNow, JavaScript.
Das haben wir uns doch schon angeguckt.
Also bleibt nur noch eine übrig, die wir uns angucken sollen.
TopCon.
Positioning.
Oh, guck mal, wie glücklich die alle sind.
Ja.
Guck mal, wie glücklich die alle sind da oben.
Die sind alle, alle super, super happy, weil generell...
Oh, das ist ja auch noch in Englisch.
Nee, ist nicht in Englisch.
Moment, wait a minute.
What?
Ah ja, ach so.
Ah, okay.
Die...
Das Intro ist in Englisch.
Der Rest ist in Deutsch.
Okay, was suchen die denn?
IT-Systemadministrator.
Männlich, weiß, deutsch.
Wie immer.
TopCon Electronics.
What?
Okay.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Also wahrscheinlich, dass sie die geilsten sind und Marktführer im Bereich XY und überhaupt
eigentlich ist es das Beste dort zu arbeiten.
Never.
Wenn beim YouTube schauen einschlafen läuft, wenn ich auffahre...
Echt du hast Autoplay an?
Das kann ich nicht.
Das Funs...
Alter, übertreib halt.
Ah, nicht so laut.
Moment, das ist das gleiche.
Hups.
Ich bin verwirrt, ich habe zu viele Fenster.
Okay.
Jetzt sind wir bei der gleichen Musik rausgekommen.
Ich kann kein YouTube-Auto-Play anhaben.
Wenn ich YouTube-Auto-Play anhab, dann dauert es nicht lang.
Da kommt irgendein komischer Influencer-Dude um die Ecke und schreit mir ins Ohr.
Und dann wache ich wieder auf.
Ich mache meistens...
Also ich kann ja auch nicht mehr richtig pennen, ohne dass was im Hintergrund läuft.
Ich gucke meistens...
Wenn ich im Bett liege, mache ich ein Video an.
Und dann gucke ich die Startseite ein bisschen durch.
Und mache dann möglichst lange Videos von Leuten, wo ich weiß, dass die nicht rumschreien.
Oder irgendwie nicht rumnerven.
Mache ich dann an.
Man kann sich ja so eine temporäre Playlist erstellen in YouTube.
Dann habe ich dann so eine temporäre Playlist mit 4-5 Videos für die Nacht drinnen.
Und am Ende mache ich dann irgendeine Chill-Musik-3-Stunden-Dings.
Sollte es nicht ausreichen.
Und...
Ja.
Dann wird das geguckt.
Moin Max, ich bin gerade auf der Suche nach einem neuen Arbeitgeber.
Worauf hast du geachtet, als du deinen Arbeitgeberwechsel vollzogen hast?
Wie wird immer...
Was ist mit deiner Watch-History verkehrt?
Ich sehe das nie.
Wobei ich kriege manchmal...
Was ich manchmal kriege, ist so...
Historische Aufnahmen rekoloriert.
Oder sowas.
Letztens hatte ich auch auf der Startseite irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung.
Hitler-Rede bei Olympia.
Äh, Hitlers echte Voice rekoloriertes Video.
Wobei das ja nicht wirklich so richtig als Nazi-Content durchgeht, sondern eher schon fast als Historical.
Aber ansonsten nix in der Richtung.
Was ich auf der YouTube-Startseite bekomme, ist massig Shorts von irgendwelchen Grills.
So.
So sieht das so ein bisschen aus wie...
Moment, Moment.
YouTube?
Food-Content.
Ja, wir accepten.
Shorts.
Ja, genau.
Sowas.
Genau sowas kriege ich dann empfohlen immer.
Wo ist der denn wieder?
Fuck.
Was ist da los, man?
Aber nur.
Auf jeden Fall nicht, wenn die Kommentare schauen bei YouTube.
Warum?
Auf jeden Fall, weil es so viele Bots gibt.
Ich meine, die Bots sind sogar bei mir am Start.
Und die Bot-Comments sind ja immer so gleich aufgebaut.
Und...
Da steht dann irgendwie sowas wie...
Sehr wichtiges Video zum Thema.
Ich verfolge ihren Kanal schon sehr lange und bin jedes Mal begeistert über den neuen Content.
Und dann kommt meistens irgendwas drunter.
Jetzt ein Geheimtipp für Sie.
Der Finanz-Coach XY hier zu finden, macht ganz tolle Videos zum Thema.
Ich habe schon letztes Jahr eine Million passives Einkommen gemacht.
schauen sie jetzt auch hier bald ist es nicht mehr da oder oder es gibt die es
gibt es gibt ja eigentlich doch noch eine andere sorte von bots die gibt es
ja schon ewig so nach dem motto visit my profile for sexy pictures die gibt es
aber nicht erst seit gestern auf youtube die gibt es schon überall schon schon
schon immer gefühlt aber es scheint ja zu gehen
sonst gibt es den scam nicht mehr da schreiben nur noch fast bots mit bots
also ganz so schlimm ist es auch nicht nur mal guckst bei mir gucken wir das
gucken wir das letzte video an das sind alles normale leute bis auf am
anfang am anfang sind wieder die bots x übrigens habe ich schon mal gesagt wie
unklar mario dankeschön für den zapf wie unglaublich mich endlos scroll
gezwungene endlos scroll auf dem desktop abfuckt
drei jahre
ich glaube ich habe das gefühl jeden zweiten stream erzählt wie sehr mich
wie sehr mich endlos scroll abfuckt aber hier ist mal wieder das beste beispiel
für ich kann ich kann nicht einfach an den anfang meine youtube kommentare
springen geht einfach nicht da muss man jetzt endlos scrollen bis man unten ist
die leute hier am start kann das sein dass die ganzen bots
wechseln weil hier sind keine hier sind keine bot kommentare mehr youtube braucht
aber ewig die rauszufiltern ja dauert halt ja bei neuen videos ist richtig viel
spam ja keine ahnung ja webdesign ist echt so ein ding ich bin mir
unschlüssig ob sich das alles zum positiven verändert hat also vieles ja
zum beispiel das javascript jetzt eine relativ gute sprache ist im vergleich zum javascript
vielleicht zu früher hat sich vieles vieles verbessert von webentwicklung her paar sachen
sind immer noch weird champ ja zum beispiel dass ein einfaches projekt 850 npm package
als abhängigkeit hat aber auch webdesign mäßig ist einiges sehr überall ist es ver-tabletisiert
ver-mobilisiert und auch oftmals total unsinnig so dass es nicht mehr richtig benutzbar ist
was gibt es ja
ändert aber halt nichts daran wie die usability von den meisten webseiten ist
ja dann lasst uns doch mal kurz die letzte position angucken die wir noch haben weil
bei top top position top con positioning also ich weiß nicht wer das ist die machen
gnss das ist irgendwelches gps oder so irgendwie irgendwelche navigations positioning dinger ich
weiß nicht wofür versteht es denn überhaupt nicht
global navigation satellite system okay ja eher für bauern machen die das unser zeug alles klar
so und die suchen einen it system administrator da musst du mal sagen die sind die sind aber
ausführlich ja die sind aber ausführlich ich hoffe es ist nicht so viele viele stellenanzeigen die
ausführlich sind habe ich manchmal den eindruck die sind jet gpt powered dieses typische also ich
keine ahnung ob das jetzt der fall sein wird dieses typische
gelaber von chat gpt also der it administrator der it system administrator ist verantwortlich
für design analyse das ist chat gpt oder das liest dass der anfang liest sich schon krass
chat gpt der it system administrator ist verantwortlich für design analyse bewertung
tests bereitstellung installation konfiguration betrieb und wartung von it system hardware
software und dazugehörigen tools und infrastrukturen und unterstützt engineering software entwicklung
Okay, wie schreibe ich in einem Satz, dass derjenige einfach alles nur Erdenkliche machen soll,
möglichst vage, dass am Ende keiner weiß, was er eigentlich wirklich machen soll?
Das finde ich immer unglaublich unsinnig, das so zu schreiben.
Das ist, das ist, also wirklich, egal was dir in der IT einfällt,
du kannst alles irgendwie unter diesem Punkt zusammenfassen.
Wahrscheinlich musst du gar nicht alles machen.
Das ist aber so super vage gehalten.
Selbst wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, tausche das Thermostat im Bad und binde es wieder in das WiFi ein.
So, das selbst, das würde quasi so da irgendwie drunter fallen.
Oder geh in den Keller und wechsel das Öl von der USV oder so.
Vom USV-Motor.
Das kannst du alles irgendwie da drunter, Infrastruktur.
Das kannst du alles, weil Infrastruktur ist ja normalerweise sowas wie Cloud-Infrastruktur,
aber das kannst du, wenn du es genau nimmst, das ist, du bist, das ist eher ein Full-Stack-Hausmeister, genau.
Da kannst du alles drunter, drunter zusammenfassen.
Da fällt sogar Klima, da fällt alles drunter, ja.
Okay, sie beteiligen sich an der technischen Forschung und, an der technischen Forschung, so, so,
und Entwicklung, die meinen damit eigentlich sowas wie, ich glaube, das ist einfach nur Pepega übersetzt,
die meinen damit sowas wie,
dass man halt ein bisschen Research, äh, Research ist falsch,
dass man halt so ein bisschen, wie nennt man das, ähm,
dass man, dass man sich einarbeitet und, und, äh,
Technologien evaluiert und sowas, die meinen damit nicht wirklich Forschung im Sinne von, äh, High-IQ-Pfeifert-Kram.
So, Forschung und Entwicklung, um kontinuierliche Innovationen innerhalb der Infrastruktur zu ermöglichen
und stellen sicher, dass alle Hardware, Betriebssysteme, Software und zugehörige Verfahren den Organisatorinnen und Betriebsgeräten und Standards entsprechen.
Alter, diese zwei Dinger sind so allgemein und, und universell geschrieben, das kannst du doch, kannst du doch eigentlich komplett vergessen, oder?
Sie übernehmen die tägliche Unterstützung von Systemdiensten einschließlich Windows, Mac, Linux-Workstations,
mobilen Smartphone-Geräten, Windows- und Linux-Servern, Cloud und Nicht-Cloud, physisch und virtuell, Netzwerken, Backup-Tools, Überwachung, CAD, Zusammenarbeit, kontinuierliche Integration, Code-Reposit-Tools, System-Dienste,
Netzwerke, Backup-Tools, Überwachung, CAD, Zusammenarbeit, kontinuierliche Integration, Code-Reposit-Tools, System-Dienste,
Netzwerke, Backup-Tools, System-Dienste,
Wer hat das Ding denn wieder geschrieben, Mann?
Also entweder ist das wirklich eine Chat-GPT-Generated-Anzeige,
oder die haben echt keine Ahnung, was sie eigentlich wollen.
Wisst ihr, wahrscheinlich, ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie es ist, so meine Einschätzung.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Stelle gar nicht kacke,
aber als, wie soll man sagen, als potenzieller Kandidat ist die Stellenausschreibung oftmals das erste,
wo man mit einem Unternehmen so in Kontakt kommt.
Außer den großen, du kennst ja die meisten Läden gar nicht.
Und wenn er schon gleich so aussieht, hast du gar keinen Bock, dich da zu bewerben.
Es ist umgedreht ja genauso.
Das erste, wo die mit den Leuten in Kontakt kommen, ist das Anschreiben,
beziehungsweise meistens halt die gesamte Bewerbung, wenn man die irgendwie hochlädt.
Viele wollen da teilweise gar kein Anschreiben mehr.
Viele sagen ja, ne, scheiß auf Anschreiben, ist gar nicht mal Pflicht.
Und das ist halt einfach ein ziemlich mieser erster Eindruck.
Okay.
Sie benötigen Kenntnisse über Systemdesigns für Serverkomponenten.
Was darf man sich denn bitte schön darunter vorstellen?
Ich kann die CPU zusammenlöten oder was?
Sie benötigen Kenntnisse über Systemdesigns für Serverkomponenten,
einschließlich Prozessoren, Festplatten-Arrays, Speicher, Betriebssysteme, Hypervisoren.
Das haben die, okay, das ist Chat-GPT unschlecht übersetzt.
So wie Cloud-basierter Datenverarbeitung, Speicherung und zugehöriger Dienste.
Alles klar.
Es geht noch weiter.
Also wer jetzt gedacht, oh fuck, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Wer jetzt gedacht hätte, das war's, nein, nein, das war's, das war so lange nicht.
Sie übernehmen die Verantwortung für Verwaltung und Überwachung und Sicherung der Infrastruktur,
Tools und einschließlich der Produktion, ha, wait a minute.
Einschließlich der Produktionsanlagen.
Vielleicht wollen sie sagen, einschließlich der produktiven Umgebung,
aber einschließlich der Produktionsanlagen heißt auch, du guckst, dass das Fließband noch ordentlich rollt.
Vielleicht haben die, die haben das auf Chat-GPT in Japan, ne Moment, die sind, kommen nicht aus Japan.
Das ist Foxconn, was du meinst.
Die hier kommen aus den USA, schreiben sie zumindest selbst im Intro-Text.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Wartung, Aktualisierung oder Implementation?
Von vorhandenen und neuen Servern für Windows- oder Linux-Betriebssysteme, je nach Anforderungen des Unternehmens.
Okay, ja.
Erleichterung, das ist immer noch nicht fertig, gell.
Das ist immer noch nicht fertig.
Erleichterung bei der Entwicklung und Einführung von Anwendungen, um ihre Arbeit schneller und effizienter zu gestalten.
Wie Git, Analytics und so weiter.
Der Satz ergibt absolut keinen Sinn.
Heißt Implementierung.
Implementationen.
Ich glaube, die Implementierung ist Einzahl, Implementationen ist Mehrzahl, oder?
Oh ne, das ist Implementierungen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Der Satz ergibt doch eigentlich keinen Sinn, oder?
Um ihre Arbeit schneller und effizienter zu gestalten.
Und dann kommt, wie Git, Analytics und so weiter.
Ja, was? Wie?
Git, Analytics und so weiter.
Ist übrigens immer noch nicht fertig.
Recherche.
Recherche, Implementierung und Testung von neuer Software, die in allen Bereichen einen Mehrwert für das Unternehmen schaffen kann.
Sie kommunizieren mit den Kollegen an den internationalen Standorten und dem Haupt...
Ah, das ist das Headquarter in den USA.
Okay.
Also sie wollen...
Okay, das Übliche.
Drei Jahre vergleichbare Berufserfahrung mit relevanter und erfolgreicher Erfahrung in der Verwaltung und Unterstützung von IT-Infrastruktur vorzugsweise einer europäischen...
...internationalen Produktion oder Fertigung.
Ihr Fachgebiet umfasst idealerweise ausgezeichnete Kenntnisse der Windows-Betriebssysteme und von MS Office.
Und oben erzählt ihr die ganze Zeit was von Linux.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
MS Office, Mann.
Das ist voll random einfach zwischendrin, Mann.
MS Office.
Ja, Windows, meinetwegen habt ihr...
Aber...
MS Office, okay.
Ein gutes Verständnis von Netzwerk-, Speicher- und Cloud-basierter Infrastruktur?
Das ist komplett...
Das ist ein komplett sinnlos Satz.
Bindestrich bedeutet ja an der Stelle eigentlich, dass du dieses Wort hinter alles so nach dem Motto setzt oder...
Oder dann halt wenigstens...
Also ein gutes Verständnis von Netzwerk-basierter, Speicher-basierter und Cloud-basierter Infrastruktur.
Was ist Speicherbasierter?
Speicherbasierter Infrastruktur.
Die meinen sowas wie Storage-Systeme wahrscheinlich.
Aber niemand nennt es speicherbasierter Infrastruktur.
Erfahrung mit Netzwerksicherheit und Disaster-Recovery-Planung.
Fähigkeit zum Installieren, Konfigurieren, Verwalten, Warten, Beheben und Bewerten von Windows- und Linux-Server-Computern, Betriebssystemen und zugehörigen Komponenten.
Zum Beispiel Speicher.
Alter, diese Stellenanzeige ist ja dermaßen mies.
Versteht und kann IP-Netzwerkkonzepte anwenden.
Switching, Routing, Adressierung und Sicherheitskompetenz...
Ey, das ist der einzig bisher sinnige Punkt dabei, der ganzen Sache.
Entwickelt, dokumentiert und implementiert Standard-Arbeitsanweisungen, Kundendienstrichtlinien in Bezug auf den IT-Support.
Achso, IT-Support auch noch.
Na, natürlich.
Wäre ja auch zu einfach gewesen, alles oben und dann noch IT-Support, ohne IT-Support.
Sorgen Sie für die Einhaltung von Unternehmensrichtlinien und Erfahrungen und Verfahren und bleiben Sie über die neuesten Technologien und Verfahren.
Und Branche entwickeln...
Ja, ja, okay.
Fähigkeit, IT-Projekte zu leiten.
Es hört ja nicht auf, Mann.
Es hört ja einfach nicht auf.
Die wollen ja wirklich alles, aber komplett alles, Mann.
Sind die noch ganz bei Trost oder was?
Was ist das?
Das kannst du noch nicht mal mehr mit schlecht übersetzt oder Chat-GPT rechtfertigen.
Selbst wenn das Chat-GPT und danach schlecht übersetzt ist, hat es einfach niemand mit ein bisschen Hirn und Verstand durchgelesen, bevor sie das da reingestellt haben.
Wisst ihr?
Ich meine, ich bin da zu faul für, aber ich habe mir schon öfters überlegt.
Wisst ihr, was man machen müsste?
Mittlerweile mit AI ist das doch gar kein Problem.
Man generiert sich ein AI-Foto und bewirbt sich da drauf mit Fake-Daten und einer Fake-E-Mail-Adresse.
Und einer Fake-Adresse.
Die antworten dir ja nicht an die echte Adresse.
Aber man bewirbt sich drauf, nicht etwa irgendwie seriös, sondern auch mit Chat-GPT.
Man sagt quasi Chat-GPT generiert und dann gucken wir mal, was da zurückkommt.
Der Bewerbungs-Champ, ja.
Peter Agile bewirbt sich.
Dann kriegst du einen Arbeitsvertrag gecheckt, ja.
Okay, Moment, Moment, es geht immer noch nicht weiter.
Verfolgen und es geht immer noch nicht, es ist immer noch nicht fertig.
Verfolgen und verwalten von Arbeitsaufzeichnungen.
Arbeitsaufzeichnungen.
Was soll das, was soll das überhaupt bedeuten?
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Was möchten die mir überhaupt sagen?
Verfolgen und verwalten von Arbeitsaufzeichnungen.
Was bedeutet der Satz?
Zeiterfassung?
Ich kann da nix, ich versteh den Satz nicht.
Okay, es geht, es geht noch weiter, es geht noch weiter, das war's ja noch nicht.
Kenntnis in MSCE.
Was ist denn MSCE überhaupt?
Microsoft Certified System Engineer.
Cloud-Plattform AZ100, äh, ich hab zwei dieser AZ-Schulungen sogar gemacht.
AZ100, Microsoft Azure Infrastrukturbereitstellung, blablabla.
MSCA, Linux und Azure, LFCS, Windows, Azure, Office 365, VMWare, 6.5 oder höher.
VM Backup Management, Linux.
Verschiedene Betriebssysteme wie CentOS, Ubuntu, Linux.
Linux Mint und so weiter.
Windows 2012 Server, Containerlösungen.
Linux und Windows.
Gibt es überhaupt Containerlösungen unter Windows?
Und jetzt sagt mir nicht Docker für Windows, weil das sind keine Container.
Verschiedene Anwendungen wie Git, Artifactory, Motomo.
Ist, ist das nicht, ist das nicht ein PHP-Webshop?
Ach nee, Analytics ist das.
Das hab ich jetzt, das hab ich jetzt.
Gibt es nicht Analytics?
Gibt es nicht, gibt es nicht nen, nen, nen Webshop, der ganz ähnlich heißt?
Ja.
Sie sind ein enthusiastischer, autonomer, praxisorientierter und serviceorientierter Fachmann, Fachfrau
mit ausgeprägten, analytischen, organisatorischen und problemlösenden Fähigkeiten.
Sie sprechen fließend Deutsch und fügen auch eine gute mündlich-schriftliche Englischkenntnisse.
Unser Angebot.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ihr müsst jetzt ja...
Mal richtig, richtig reinhauen, wenn ihr so jemand haben wollt.
Was bietet ihr denn?
Ein sehr kollegiales Team, geprägt von Gemeinschaftssinn.
Ja, davon kann ich mir nix kaufen.
Das ist nice, das ist nice.
Aber, sagen wir mal so, das sollte die Basis sein für ordentliches Arbeiten, ja.
Homeoffice ist möglich.
Ach ja, okay.
Ein Tag im Monat, oder wie?
Bringen Sie gerne eigene Ideen und Vorschläge mit.
Anbindung an ein internationales Arbeitsumfeld.
Flexible Arbeitszeit, Gestaltung, Spielraum und Offenheit.
Also bis jetzt habe ich noch nix gelesen, was wirklich irgendwas Besonderes wäre,
beziehungsweise was, warum ich sagen würde, oh ja, da muss man hin.
Ihre berufliche Weiterentwicklung wird durch ein Umfang...
Okay, bla bla bla, Fortbildungsmaßnahmen, 30 Tage Urlaub, das ist eigentlich Standard.
Betriebliche Altersversorgung, Gesundheitsmanagement ist auch fast, fast Standard.
Kostenlose Versorgung mit einem Arbeitsumfeld.
Mit Wasser, Kaffee und der Obstkorb.
Wo ist der Obstkorb?
Teilnahme an Firmenveranstaltungen.
Das soll ein Plus sein, oder was?
Bitte senden Sie uns Ihre Bewerbung auch auf Englisch, beziehungsweise in englischer Sprache zu.
Jetzt bewerben.
Automatisch ausfüllen mit Lebenslauf, okay.
Was passiert da jetzt, wenn man da draufklickt?
Indem Sie Ihren Lebenslauf hochladen.
Äh, was hat das jetzt bitte schön mit automatisch ausfüllen zu tun?
Manuell bewerben.
Ach so.
Ach, bei dem anderen hätte er das automatisch erkannt aus dem Lebenslauf, oder was?
Wisst ihr was?
Ich glaube, wir bewerben uns da mal just for fun.
Mit Fake-Namen und Fake-Avatar und Fake-E-Mail.
Aber wir müssen so richtig dick auftragen dann.
Ich liebe es, IT-Projekte zu leiten.
Mein zweiter Vorname ist Cloud-Container-Lösung.
Irgendwie, das muss richtig cringe sein.
Peter Agilebe, 40.
Kennt ihr mal einen guten Avatar-Generator, der quasi Bilder?
Aber gab es nicht von Nvidia dieses
This person does not exist
für Gesichter-Generating?
Aber da gibt es mittlerweile bestimmt bessere, ja.
Genau das meine ich.
This person does not exist, ja.
Aber das ist noch altes Generating.
Ah, hier haben wir schon mal so ein Business-Dude, Alter.
War das nicht Nvidia?
Ist, ist alt, ja.
Ich bewerbe mich mal und frage...
Ja, ja, ja, Gehalt.
Na, na komm, was ist...
Also ich meine, wenn ich alles kann in der Richtung,
dann können wir schon mal sagen, mein Gehalt ist...
Wir schreiben einfach rein.
Gehaltswunsch 250.000 Euro.
Mal gucken, was wir dann schreiben.
Oh Mann, das hatten wir schon.
Oh Mann, Alter, das ist so...
Das ist so schlecht.
Wisst ihr?
Und dann wird sich beschwert...
So nach dem Motto...
Oh nein, Fachkräftemangel.
Wir finden niemanden, der das macht.
Naja.
Dann lasst uns mal kurz gucken,
was auf...
Ich speichere das mal.
Was auf ShitHub trendet.
Ich explore.
Trend.
Trending.
Nicht monatlich,
sondern diese Woche.
Bestimmt jedem...
Ah ja, okay.
AI.
Nee.
Lirt.
Low latency.
Runtime.
Aha.
Das ist eine JavaScript-Runtime für Cloud-Functions.
Da werden jetzt die ganzen Rust-Fans sagen,
warum sollte man sowas denn bitte schön in JavaScript machen,
wenn man das auch in Rust machen kann.
Eine...
legitime Frage.
Moneyprinter.
Automate creation of YouTube-Shorts using MoviePie.
Okay.
Man kann YouTube mit Shorts spammen
und damit Geld machen.
Da bezweifle ich ja...
Das ist deprecated.
Okay.
Da bezweifle ich ja, dass das gut funktioniert.
Das bezweifle ich, dass das sinnlich sinnlich funktioniert.
Wir sind letztens mal über so ein Auto-generatedes Video gestolpert.
Das war so schlecht, man.
Nee, das haben wir uns noch nicht angeschaut.
Das ist das...
Das...
Apple Jason meinst du, gell?
Beziehungsweise das Apple...
Apple Je...
Je...
Jean.
Okay, ich glaube, dass...
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass das zu 100% funktioniert,
aber dass du nur ein paar Cent verdienst.
Okay.
AI.
Hier ist PK...
PKL.
AI.
Brauch man net.
Edgard Home.
AI.
3D-Drucker.
Firmware.
Ach nee.
Nee, das verwechselt das immer.
Nicht 3D-Drucker, Firmware.
Wifi, Dingsbums, Device, Firmware.
Object Detection.
It's sudo for Windows.
Hat Windows nicht schon Run S total lange?
Warum gibt's es jetzt sudo?
Wollt man nicht schon ewig Run S machen?
Ja.
Ist aber auch gut.
Muss man sich nicht umgewöhnen.
Ist wahrscheinlich ein Alias, ja.
AI.
Äh.
Okay.
Sehr unspektakulär.
Und langweilig, was da diese Woche trendet, muss ich sagen.
Oh Leute, ich hab jetzt schon Hunger.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Es ist erst 11.
Aber ich bin ja schon gerannt.
Ah, Moment.
Ich muss mal kurz was checken auf meinem Handy.
Nee, keine Sorge.
Ich geh noch nicht off, aber...
Ich wollte ja mal kurz gucken,
wie das heute lief beim Rennen.
Am Anfang nicht.
Ey, Leute, ich kann nicht langsam rennen, gell.
Ich hab's probiert am Anfang.
Ich hab mich richtig gezwungen langsam zu rennen.
So 6,45, teilweise 7 Minuten pro Kilometer.
Richtig langsam, niedriger Puls und so.
Aber ab...
Sag mal so, ab der Hälfte, hatte ich so das Gefühl, dass es einfach, ist mir einfach zu lahm.
Und dann bin ich wieder, bin ich wieder schneller gerannt.
So, wenn ich am Ende nicht so 160, 165 Puls hab,
denke ich, ich hab nix geschafft.
Und jetzt hab ich wieder ungefähr den gleichen Pace im Durchschnitt gehabt.
Ein bisschen langsamer, wie sonst immer.
Ich krieg das einfach nicht auf die Reihe, langsam zu rennen.
Ich muss immer so mein Tempo rennen, was sich gut anfühlt.
Ja, wie immer.
6,5...
6,5 kmh?
Das ist super langsam.
Meinst du wirklich 6,5 kmh?
Oder meinst du...
6,5 Minuten pro Kilometer?
Laut Komoot...
Kmh?
Ja, da bist du gelaufen, oder?
Da bist du schnell gelaufen.
Also, gegangen.
Schnell gegangen.
So, 9 ist gerade, würde ich sagen, der Übergang von schnellem Gehen zu super, super langsamem Laufen vielleicht.
Näh.
Das bringt ja nix.
Das bringt ja nix, wenn ich mich zu irgendwas zwinge, was sich nicht gescheit anfühlt, so.
Aber 150 ist auch ein bisschen niedrig.
Ich meine, ich bin zwar schon älter, aber ich hab immer noch einen maximalen Puls von 192.
Das darf ruhig, darf bei mir ruhig ein bisschen höher sein.
So.
Also, hier ist alles geupdatet.
Wunderbar.
Spaziergang zum Bäcker, zwei Dörfer weiter.
Für einen Spaziergang ist 9er-Schnitt relativ schnell.
Also, alles unter 10,30.
10 ist ziemlich schnelles Laufen.
Also, Gehen.
Weil viele fangen ja, wenn sie anfangen zu joggen, beziehungsweise zu rennen, fangen sie ja so mit 8,30 an.
Das ist so...
Oftmals so einsteigen.
Das ist so einsteigergeschwindigkeit.
Ja, nice.
Nice.
Ich hätte es auch nicht gedacht, wie schnell man da drinnen besser wird, aber das bestätigt sich immer wieder.
Habe ich ja schon öfters gesagt.
Man glaubt gar nicht, wie schnell man, wie schnell man irgendwas gut werden kann.
Ich hätte auch nicht gedacht, dass ich mal 10 Kilometer am Stück renne und danach nicht quasi ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert werden muss.
Ist das nicht zu viel Puls?
Nö.
Das kommt ja auch immer ein bisschen drauf an.
Wie viel du so...
Also, ja.
Wie trainiert du bist, wie viel du sonst so machst und alles.
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Wichtig ist, auf jeden Fall, unabhängig davon, ich bin ja da wirklich kein Wissenschaftler in der Richtung, was das angeht.
Wichtig ist auf jeden Fall, dass man das regelmäßig macht.
Aber 120 ist eindeutig zu wenig für mich.
120 habe ich ja schon beim schnellen Gehen.
Also, wenn ich das hier laufe, wie hier der Kyoto-Kesel...
Wenn ich das so heute Morgen laufe, dann habe ich locker 120, 125, vielleicht sogar 130.
Aber wie gesagt, bei mir geht es auch bis 192.
Also, es ist vollkommen okay, wenn ich da mit 150 rumlaufe.
Also, heute hatte ich, kann ich euch sagen, Puls 155 im Durchschnitt.
Am Anfang weniger, am Ende mehr.
10 Kilometer rennen ist Aufnahme-Prüfung beim SEK.
Ja gut, da würde ich auch erwarten, dass die Leute ein gewisses Fitnesslevel brauchen.
Und bestimmt auch in einer gewissen Zeit, oder?
Weil, ich behaupte einfach mal, 10 Kilometer am Stück rennen können die meisten, es kommt ein bisschen auf die Geschwindigkeit an.
Also, ich kann auch so tun, als würde ich laufen mit 11 Minuten pro Kilometer.
Dann sieht das halt einfach nur aus, als würde ich joggen.
Aber in Wirklichkeit laufe ich halt, gehe ich halt.
Und das packen die meisten.
Also, die meisten...
Wenn man jetzt nicht komplett zu den, keine Ahnung, so 5% gehört, die sowas...
Also, ich gehe davon aus, die meisten der Leute schaffen 10 Kilometer am Stück in, ja, weiß ich nicht.
Wenn du denen 3 Stunden Zeit gibst, easy.
Also, ich brauche ungefähr so knapp über eine Stunde für 10 Kilometer.
Und wenn ich mal Vollgas geben würde, wahrscheinlich auch unter einer Stunde.
Aber ich habe mich bisher nicht dazu durchringen können.
Mein Ziel ist ja, wenn es wieder warm wird, mal 20 Kilometer zu rennen, quasi von Hanau nach Seelinkenstadt und von Seelinkenstadt nach Hanau zurück.
Allerdings nicht direkt am Stück, sondern 10 Kilometer hin, mal kurz da ein bisschen Pause machen, was trinken, was futtern.
Ich habe so eine Weste zum Umhängen, da kann man so eine Trinkflasche reinmachen und irgendwie so zwei, drei Riegel oder so reinstecken.
Und dann setze ich mich da kurz eine Viertelstunde hin oder 10 Minuten hin, trink was und futtere ein, zwei Riegel und dann renne ich wieder heim.
Oh ja, das hatte ich auch schon.
Einmal, wo es richtig warm draußen war, bin ich vom Hauptbahnhof zurückgerannt.
Hanau Hauptbahnhof zurück.
Das ist nicht weit, das sind auch nur irgendwie, ja, so 6 Kilometer oder so, 6,5 Kilometer.
Das mache ich wahrscheinlich auch dann.
Und da konnte ich, da bin ich die Brücke hochgerannt und danach konnte ich eigentlich nur noch laufen, weil es mir, mir ist schlecht, mir ist schlecht geworden.
Weil das so warm war.
Daran habe ich gedacht, ich übertreibe es jetzt lieber mal nicht, mach mal langsam.
Also wenn es einem anfängt schlecht zu werden von Belastung und Wärme, ist meistens keine gute Idee.
Ich brauche auf jeden Fall, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich hoffe, dass es wieder demnächst ein bisschen wärmer und schon ein bisschen Sonne wird.
Und ich brauche auf jeden Fall auch wieder ein Fahrrad.
Richtig Bock, wieder Fahrrad zu fahren, MonkaS.
Also nicht nur hier auf meinem, auf meinem Trainer, sondern halt auch draußen wieder.
Und dafür brauche ich halt mal ein gescheites Fahrrad.
Ja, aber es gibt ja gerade keins.
Ich hätte mir schon eins gekauft.
Ich hätte mir schon eins gekauft, wenn es eins in meiner Größe gibt.
Ich wollte mir genau das gleiche wieder kaufen, was ich habe, beziehungsweise was ich hatte.
Übrigens, es gibt Neuigkeiten von der Versicherung.
Wollt ihr mal lachen?
Ähm.
Moment, Moment.
Ich suche euch mal kurz die Mail raus.
Glücklicherweise habe ich das über einen Anwalt gemacht, weil da wäre ich jetzt herrlich, wäre ich schon wieder ausgerastet bei, wenn ich das gelesen hätte.
Pass mal auf.
Also, ich habe dieses Fahrrad hier.
Ich zeige es euch mal, was es normalerweise kostet hier.
So, das, das Fahrrad habe ich.
Das, das habe ich neu gekauft für irgendwie, für das da.
Ja, ich, ich habe irgendwie 3.400 Euro so in dem Dreh bezahlt.
Also exakt das, leider gibt es das aktuell nicht in meiner Größe.
Exakt das Fahrrad habe ich.
So.
Und da hat mich ja eine über den Haufen gefahren und das Fahrrad ist laut Gutachten ein Totalschaden.
Das Gutachten haben sie auch anerkannt und alles und so, ist klar.
So, und jetzt haben die geantwortet von der Versicherung.
Wie gesagt, glücklicherweise geht das über den Anwalt, weil sonst wäre ich wieder ultra abgefuckt gewesen.
Die haben geantwortet.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, den Schaden regulieren wir wie folgt.
Ey, passt mal auf.
Mittlerweile sind die, die Gutachterkosten, die Gutachterkosten sind bei 850 Euro und die Anwaltskosten sind bei knapp 1.900 Euro.
1.900 Euro müssen die für den Anwalt bezahlen extra jetzt noch.
Das ist schon ordentlich, ne?
So, und jetzt kommt's, und jetzt kommt's, das ist mir ja egal, aber jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt der Hit.
Also.
Sie haben gesagt, Prüfung hat stattgefunden mit abweichendem Ergebnis.
Die ursprüngliche Kalkulation, also sprich das, was wir denen dahin geschickt haben, was der Sachverständige gesagt hat, sind 3.621 Euro.
Da ist wahrscheinlich auch Ausfall oder so schon mit dabei, keine Ahnung.
3.621.
Und sie sagen, aber sie wollen bloß 2.199 Euro bezahlen.
Und die Erklärung ist, die Höhe ist in der Fahrradbranche, Moment, das Neuwert des Rades beträgt 2.199 Euro.
Wisst ihr, was die gemacht haben?
Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass das Absicht ist.
Die sind hier hingegangen und haben gesagt, okay, nicht Sales, die sind hingegangen hier auf die, auf die Webseite, die haben auch das verlinkt.
Warum ist die Seite auf einmal so?
So, so weird.
Die sind hingegangen und haben einfach das kleinste Fahrrad irgendwie genommen.
Ich finde noch nicht mal eins für 2.199, Mann.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die überhaupt gesucht haben, ne?
2.199.
Ah, hier steht ja auch, was sie für eins haben.
Zu den Modellen, hier.
GRX, GRX 600 haben sie rausgesucht.
Also, die haben halt gemeint, das da, das da wäre guter Ersatz für...
Für mein Fahrrad.
Das ist halt ein komplett anderes Rad, ne?
So.
Und, so, und dann haben sie ein bisschen, ein bisschen rumgelabert noch.
Zumindest.
Mein Anwalt hat dann natürlich drauf geantwortet und hat gesagt, ähm, er widerspricht der Sache.
Man sieht doch auch hier auf der, also sinngemäß hat er geschrieben, man sieht doch auch hier auf der Rechnung, was das Fahrrad gekostet hat.
Und, er fordert sie auf, den...
Den fehlenden Betrag von 1.700 Euro noch zusätzlich zu überweisen.
Und die Anwaltsgebühren werden immer höher.
Also, ich bin froh, dass ich das direkt an den Anwalt gegeben habe.
Ich bin froh, dass ich das direkt an den Anwalt gegeben habe, weil sonst müsste ich mich selbst mit denen rumschlagen.
Jaja.
Nein, nein, die Versicherung bezahlt den Anwalt.
Ich musste noch nicht einen Cent an den Anwalt bezahlen.
Ich habe dem das erklärt, wie das passiert ist.
Der hat sich das auf Google Maps angeguckt und hat gesagt, ja, macht er.
Ähm, dann musste ich unterschreiben, dass ich die Zahlung abtrete.
An die gegnerische Versicherung oder sowas.
Und jetzt stellt er das denen in Rechnung.
Warum müssen die den Anwalt bezahlen?
Naja, weil die auch komplett dran schuld sind.
Beziehungsweise diejenige, die sie vertreten, da komplett dran schuld ist.
Ich gehe davon aus, weil es ist mehr, als das Fahrrad gekostet hat.
Insofern.
Ne, ne, den Anwalt hier bei mir um die Ecke.
Ja.
Das nächste Mal.
Da muss ich mal überlegen.
Die hat mich im November umgefahren.
November, Dezember, Januar, Februar.
Vier Monate und ich habe die Kohle noch nicht.
Das ist halt einfach lächerlich.
Es stört mich ja auch gar nicht so sehr, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich meine, ich habe genug Kohle, um mir ein neues Fahrrad kaufen zu können.
Es gibt ja gar kein neues.
Gerade in der Konfiguration, wie ich das haben will.
Und es war jetzt eh Winter.
Aber es ist halt schon lächerlich.
Wenn du dir überlegst, wenn jemand auf das angewiesen ist.
Ja.
Dann kannst du halt komplett vergessen.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn es komplett klar ist, sollte sowas unter einem Monat gehen.
Der, also.
Das kann ich dir nicht genau sagen.
Der Sachverständige hat geschrieben, ich glaube 15 Euro pro Tag.
Als Empfehlung.
Also wenn das vier Monate, hier 4 mal 3 ist ja 120, kann ich auch sagen.
120 mal 15.
Ja, gibt es fast noch ein halbes Fahrrad dabei dann.
Ich denke mal, dass er das sogar.
Dass er das sogar.
Mit eingerechnet hat.
Also sie sind selbst dran schuld, wenn sie nicht.
Beikommen.
Ist auch gut, da soll die so richtig, da soll die so richtig ausnehmen, Mann.
Und den maximalen Kram für sich auch noch abrechnen.
Ist mir egal.
Hauptsache ich krieg die Kohle und kann mein neues Fahrrad kaufen.
Wobei, wie gesagt, wenn es eins geben würde, ich würde mir jetzt auch eins kaufen.
Kackladen.
Na gut, was gibt's denn auf YouTube schönes zu gucken?
Nee.
Ich will keine Federgabel.
Vorne sehe ich den Sinn nicht drinne.
Die Wege, die ich fahre, sind jetzt ja nicht irgendwelche extrem holprigen Waldwege.
Die einzige Sache, wo es ganz cool gewesen wäre, ist bei den ganzen verwurzelten Meinradwegen, die es hier unten gibt.
Aber das geht auch ohne.
Ey, wenn du eins hast, beziehungsweise wenn du eins findest.
Das das Blöde ist halt, dass es die Schaltung noch gar nicht gibt.
Also ich jetzt aus zwei Gründen warte ich mit dem Neukauf.
Erstens, weil ich am liebsten wieder von Rose den gleichen Rahmen zumindest haben will, wie ich habe, weil das fand ich super bequem.
Das gibt's aber gerade nicht in meiner Größe.
Doch, machen sie.
Das gibt's aber gerade nicht in meiner Größe lieferbar.
Und außerdem möchte ich eigentlich am liebsten.
Shimano Di2 1x12.
Äh, also GRX 820 1x12.
Die Di2 müsste das dann heißen als Schaltung, und die gibt es noch gar nicht.
Also entweder gucke ich nach einem Hersteller, der das halt mit irgendeiner anderen 1x12 von SRAM oder so macht.
Oder irgendwie die Komponenten so mischt, dass es passt.
Weil Rose hat das nicht.
Und nachdem ich jetzt einmal elektronische Schaltung gefahren bin, habe ich keinen Bock mehr mechanische Schaltung zu fahren.
Es ist einfach nice.
Wurden die denn schon angekündigt oder hoffst du das einfach nur?
Ähm, halbe halbe.
Ich hoffe das.
Und so inoffiziell hört man schon, dass das nicht mehr lange dauern kann.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es das gibt.
Aber das will ich doch nicht, habe ich gerade gesagt.
1x12 habe ich jetzt schon.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Bei Rose gibt's auch 1x12 SRAM.
Bist du eigentlich auch so froh, dass Leute über 70 jetzt doch keinen Gesundheitscheck machen müssen?
Um weiter Auto fahren zu dürfen?
Die FDP meint, das würde die Menschen die Freiheit berauben.
Ja, der Markt regelt das.
Die habe ich mir auch schon angeguckt.
Die habe ich mir tatsächlich auch schon angeguckt.
Da sitzt man aber nicht so bequem drauf.
Sieht man denn hier wenigstens, was die für eine maximale Übersetzung haben?
Ausstattung.
Ich bin 1,74.
Alle Komponenten.
Äh, 1,10 bis 1,44, joa.
Das finde ich bei den standardmäßigen 1x12 Shimano GRX Dingern gut.
Die haben, ähm, 10 bis 1,50 glaube ich.
Das heißt, selbst den steilsten Berg kommst du mit 1,51 hinten und ich glaube 42, nee, 40 vorne oder so easy hoch.
Ja, ich weiß es noch nicht.
Muss man.
Mal gucken.
Ich kaufe mir kein, ich, ich, ich mache kein Jobrad.
Ich kaufe mir das selbst.
Was gibt es bei mir in der Stadt?
So eine Straße, wo regelmäßig alte Leute in die Schaufenster von innen fahren.
Ja, schon pipiga.
Sollen, können die da nicht irgendwelche, wie soll man sagen, so, wie heißt denn das so?
Beton?
Boller aufstellen, dass sie da nicht mehr reinfahren.
J-Law am Start, moin, na?
So, gucken wir mal.
Was können wir uns denn auf YouTube?
Heute anschauen.
Was ist das hier?
Microsoft Co-Pilot für Office ist eine Frechheit.
Boah, na dann.
Ach so, stimmt.
Ja, das, das hat ja, lohnt sich das YouTube.
Das hat ja YouTube auch verschluckt, dass ich das immer mal ganz gerne gucke.
Was verdient eine Beamtin im Landratsamt?
Ich arbeite im Büro.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht so übel.
Ja.
Jetzt, jetzt übertreiben sie es aber, oder?
Wie hoch ist das Risiko eines Krieges in Deutschland?
Jetzt geht's, jetzt geht's runter.
Naja, wobei, wenn ich in, wenn ich in manche Problembezirke gucke, das ist vielleicht nicht wirklich Krieg, aber da geht's ja auch schon hart zur Sache.
Warum nicht alle in Ausbildung kommen?
Okay, also.
Nein, das wollte ich nicht gucken.
Ich wollte, ich wollte gucken, warum Microsoft Co-Pilot so schlecht ist.
Warum ist Co-Pilot so kacke?
Ich wollte einfach ein, erstelle eine Präsentation über Raspberry Pi, Martin Luther und Schokolade.
Ja, und dann erstellt PowerPoint vollautomatisch diese Präsentation.
So richtig mit animiertem Intro-Video.
Gar nicht so schlecht.
Gar nicht so schlecht, oder?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das AI-generated ist, ob der einfach Stock-Videos raussucht.
Wahrscheinlich sucht er Stock-Videos raus.
So und so.
Und sieht auch erstmal okay aus.
Alter.
Was ist das für Weep-Spam hier?
Im Chat.
Was ist hier los?
Chat-Girl.
Weeps in oder weeps out?
Okay.
Jetzt, ihr habt's nicht anders gewollt, Leute.
Ihr habt's nicht anders gewollt.
Jetzt wirst ihr durch.
Jetzt habt ihr gelitten.
Quality is destiny.
Jetzt habt ihr Penalty.
Jetzt habt ihr Pech.
Jetzt müsst ihr Weep-Musik ertragen.
Ihr wollt jetzt nicht anders.
Der Chat flippt aus.
Okay.
Genug Weep-Ladung für heute Morgen.
Was, welches Intro das ist.
Äh, wo hab ich das jetzt überhaupt aufgemacht?
Ähm, das ist jetzt eine gute Frage.
Ja.
Ähm.
Alles klar, Chat?
Nein.
Das ist das Intro.
Obviously.
Jetzt.
Ich glaube, jetzt weiß man Bescheid, ja.
Das lass ich mal in der Playlist drinnen.
Falls der Chat wieder irgendwas anstellt.
Okay.
So.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Microsoft's Copilot für Office ist eine Frechheit.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist das Intro von, wie heißt das Zeug noch, wie heißt das nochmal auf Deutsch
oder auf Englisch?
Ähm.
I killed three people.
I killed three hundred slimes and maxed out my level oder irgendwie sowas.
Ein, ich bin ja nicht so der große Anime-Gucker.
Das hat mich etwas verwirrt.
Ich hab das, ich hab das tatsächlich geguckt.
Das hat mich etwas verwirrt, weil ich mir die ganze Zeit gedacht hab, ist, die ganze
Zeit gedacht hab, ist, warum genau guck ich mir das jetzt an, bis ich dann gelernt habe,
dass das ein spezielles Genre ist.
Und zwar nennt sich dieses, das, das Genre dieses Animes, Cute Girls Doing Cute Things.
Und nein, das hat nix mit, ne, was ihr jetzt vielleicht denkt zu tun, sondern einfach
komplett belangloses Zeug.
Komplett sinnlos.
Es hat noch nicht mal ne Story im eigentlichen Sinne so richtig.
Und auch keine Tentakel oder sonst was.
Super weird so.
Keine Ahnung, ob Ayaya das auch ist.
Okay, so.
Gucken wir uns mal das Video an.
Aber total bescheuert.
Das Trio in Aktion.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Voll automatisch diese Präsentation.
So richtig mit animiertem Intro-Video und so.
Und sieht auch erstmal okay aus.
Ist innerlich aber total bescheuert.
Das Trio in Aktion.
Projektor.
Hä?
Was hat jetzt ein Projektor mit den drei Sachen?
Zu tun?
Und was hat Martin Luther mit den in einen Berg geschnitzten amerikanischen Präsidenten
zu tun?
Man weiß es nicht.
Aber auf jeden Fall.
Nix.
Aber Chat GPT fantasiert sich halt irgendwas zusammen.
Was haben jetzt alle Microsoft Office Programme?
So eine sogenannte Co-Pilot KI Funktion.
Wir haben uns die angeguckt und Anwendungsbereiche gesucht, die heute schon sinnvoll sein können.
Ob wir die gefunden haben?
Bleibt dran.
Liebe, liebe Interessenten, herzlich willkommen hier bei.
Und Werbung?
Ja.
KI, schön und gut.
Aber wusstet ihr, dass man sich über VPN nach Albanien handeln kann?
Und was kommt jetzt?
NordVPN.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Und dann im Moment fast keine Werbung mehr bekommt.
Ja.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von NordVPN.
Und mit NordVPN geht das.
Man kann sich damit auch in die USA klicken und da dann Sachen bestellen, die es hier
zu lenden nicht gibt.
Oder auch andere Filme und Serien zum Beispiel auf Netflix gucken.
Man kann aber auch Geld sparen.
Weil bei sowas wie Flügen, Mietwagen und Hotels.
Wir gucken uns jetzt wirklich.
Je nach Land, in dem die Buchung stattfindet, die Preise unterschiedlich sind.
Ja.
Also.
Wenn die Buchung stattfindet, die Preise unterschiedlich.
Lohnt sich also, das mal auszuprobieren.
Und das könnt ihr bei NordVPN mit 30.
Ja.
Also, dass es jetzt KI-Funktionen in Microsoft Office gibt, das finde ich, ist eine einigermaßen
große Sache.
Weil die Microsoft Office Software.
Mich wundert das überhaupt nicht, dass das in Office kommt.
Sie hatten ja so kleine, kleinere KI-Funktionen schon die ganze Zeit in Office.
Ja, du konntest in PowerPoint ja schon Designs generaten und Zeug machen.
Aber nachdem Microsoft ja so krass investiert hat.
Und voll dabei ist, was ChatGPT und OpenAI angeht.
Das war doch klar, dass das früher oder später auch in Office kommt.
Mit Copilot ging es los.
Jetzt gibt es ja auch Windows Copilot.
Wo ich absolut keine Ahnung habe, warum man das verwenden soll.
Und dass das jetzt Office Copilot kommt.
Heißt das Ding jetzt eigentlich Office Copilot?
Oder Microsoft 365 Copilot?
Genau genommen.
Genau genommen müsste es Microsoft 365 Copilot heißen.
Aber ich wette mit euch.
Microsoft hat es wieder geschafft, sogar ihre eigene Benahmung unsinnig wieder zu machen.
Nach wie vor der de facto Standard ist, wenn es um Texte schreiben, Präsentationen erstellen
oder Tabellenkalkulationen geht.
Word ist so useless einfach nur.
Allerdings gibt es das Ganze noch nicht automatisch dazu, sondern das kostet 22 Euro extra im Monat,
wenn ihr das zu eurem persönlichen Office 365 abonniert.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass es in dem Abo mit drin.
Weil so als weiterer Verkaufsgrund, warum man sich das Abo kaufen soll.
22 Euro im Monat.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Abo dazu buchen.
Für Business Accounts kann man das auch dazu buchen.
Das geht aber offenbar erst, wenn man mindestens 300 Lizenzen kauft.
Also das ist nur was für größere Unternehmen.
Und die Copilot KI Funktionen kosten dann auch gleich 3 Euro.
Die kosten dann auch gleich 30 US-Dollar pro Lizenz.
Also mindestens 108.000 Dollar pro Lizenz.
Ja, drunter macht es Microsoft nicht.
Also dieser Copilot muss ja echt richtig viel Produktivität schaffen.
Gucken wir uns mal genauer an.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, wie JetBrains das macht.
Ich habe auch die JetBrains AI Funktion noch nie verwendet.
Ich habe da ein persönliches Office 365 Family Abo abgeschlossen.
Das kostet regulär 99 Euro pro Jahr.
Kann man aber einen Monat lang kaufen.
Kann man einen Monat lang kostenlos ausprobieren.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was mit mir los war.
Ich habe ja auch ein Office Abo, aber einen Personal glaube ich für, was auch immer das kostet.
Ja, und es heißt ja auch gar nicht mehr Office.
Es heißt ja Microsoft 365.
Ich vergesse das immer.
Pro Tipp, direkt wieder kündigen, dann vergisst man das Abo nicht und kann es nach der Kündigung trotzdem noch einen Monat lang verwenden.
Wie auf Onlyfans.
Da oben drauf muss man dann Copilot Pro abonnieren für 22 Euro pro Monat.
Erst dann werden diese ganzen KI-Funktionen in den Office-Programm freigeschaltet.
Obendrein bekommt man den Windows Copilot, ja, den gibt es ja auch noch, als Pro-Version.
Das ist auch so ein useless Ding.
Ich habe gar keine Ahnung, warum ich jemals den Windows Copilot verwenden will.
Den Windows Copilot im Browser mit copilot.microsoft.com.
Und da seht ihr das mal im Vergleich.
Hier links ohne Abo, rechts mit.
Ja, ihr seht, da steht Copilot Pro.
Und der Unterschied ist ganz klar die Geschwindigkeit.
Und zwar bei allen der drei Optionen kreativ aus.
Microsoft 365 und Office 365, nee, es gibt nicht beides.
Chat, da hatten wir es doch das letzte Mal erst von.
Sogar Microsoft sagt, dass es jetzt Microsoft 365 heißt.
Guck, Office.com.
Office is now Microsoft 365.
Also sogar Microsoft sagt, dass es jetzt nicht Office, sondern Microsoft 365 heißt.
Ich sehe es schon.
Der Chat will es wieder.
Ja, du hast wahrscheinlich sogar recht.
Je nachdem, was man sich gekauft hat.
Wenn man sich noch Office 365 gekauft hat, dann heißt es Office 365.
Und es ist Microsoft-Logik.
Microsoft-Benahmung ist eh für den Arsch.
Gewogen oder genau.
Weil kreativ kann man bei Copilot Pro auch GPT-4 Turbo zuschalten.
Das ist dann richtig schnell.
Das flutscht sozusagen.
Also auch der Office-Copilot.
Gibt es, das ist ja nur irgendeine Test-VM von ihm.
Aber gibt es irgendjemand, der wirklich dieses Windows-Wetter-Widget verwendet?
Oder der überhaupt Windows-Widgets verwendet?
Der Copilot, also auch der Office-Copilot GPT-4 von OpenAI.
Da steckt Microsoft ja auch finanziell mit rein.
Ja, Microsoft puttert da richtig Kohle rein.
Von Windows-Copilot zu Office-Copilot.
Das kriegt ihr, wenn ihr das 22 Euro Copilot Pro Abo abgeschlossen habt.
Auf jeden Fall safe in den Browser-Varianten der Office-Programme.
Also unter office.com.
Das geht dann auch auf Macs oder Linux-Rechnern.
Wusstet ihr, dass Office eine React-basierte Anwendung ist?
Also WebOffice.
Nicht irgendwelches Microsoft-Zeug, das ist React.
Ja, das ist React.
Eigentlich sollen die KI-Funktionen auch mit den Standalone-Software-Varianten unter Windows funktionieren.
Also wenn ihr im Windows-Startmenü zum Beispiel ganz normal Word aufruft.
Die Standalone-Versionen sind auch übrigens die, die oben rechts so ein komisches Gewuschel anzeigen.
Was?
Ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Und ich dachte da immer, da ist irgendwas kaputt gegangen.
Aber das soll tatsächlich Dekoration sein.
Nämlich Wolken.
Man kann auch noch andere Dekorationen einstellen.
Aha.
Super.
Das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Vor allem, wie billig sieht das aus, oder?
Es gab mal Zeiten, da konntest du sogar die komplette Form deiner Fenster modden.
Und war dann vielleicht nicht super usable, aber sah cool aus.
Aha.
Ja, niemand verwendet Windows-Widgets.
So ein Schwachsinn.
Unsinniger Shit, Mann.
... 1997 hat angerufen und will seine Fenster-Deko zurück.
Nee, das Witz ist ja, unter Windows 95 ging das noch besser.
Ja.
Aber es gibt ja auch andere Dekorationen.
Und wenn es halt nur so ein optisches Problem ist, mit diesen kruscheligen Wolken, gibt's
leider auch handfestere Probleme mit Standalone Office und Copilot.
Wir haben nämlich auf mehreren Rechnern fiese Probleme damit gehabt.
Es gibt ja zwei unterschiedliche Microsoft-Account-Gattungen.
Ja.
By the way, ich checke immer noch nicht genau, warum das überhaupt ein Ding ist, aber okay.
Persönliche Accounts und einmal Business- und Schul- bzw.
Uni-Accounts.
Das ist ja das, was Microsoft nennt.
Es ist ja auch immer noch so, dass es für diese beiden Account-Gattungen unterschiedliche
Teams-Clients gibt.
Das habe ich ja schon ganz wieder verdrängt.
Stimmt.
Und witzigerweise ist bei Windows 11 ja ein Teams vorinstalliert, was gar kein richtiges
Teams ist.
Das ist super weird.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was sie da treiben bei Microsoft.
Es gibt also unangezweifelte Teams.
Ja.
Das ist ja auch immer noch so.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was sie da treiben bei Microsoft.
Ja.
Es gibt also unangenehm kompliziert und nervig.
Das Ding ist, wenn euer Windows irgendwie mit einem Business- oder Schul-Account in
Kontakt gekommen ist, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass Office seine Lizenz daher holen
will, also aus dem Business-Account.
Das ist aber doof, weil wir ja das Copilot Pro Abo auf unserem persönlichen Account
gebucht haben und darüber auch das Office Family Abo läuft.
Ja, und zumindest wir haben auf mehreren Testrechnern das Problem gehabt, dass wir das nicht einfach
umschalten konnten.
Wir mussten also Windows 11 komplett neu installieren, damit sich Office die richtige Lizenz zieht,
damit Copilot auf den Standalone-Office-Programm läuft.
Also ihr seid gewarnt.
Hä?
Okay, Microsoft.
Microsoft.
Things.
Wenn ihr das ausprobieren wollt und ihr auf dem System irgendwo ein Business-Microsoft-Account
laufen habt.
Naja.
Also die Cloud-Versionen laufen auch da problemlos mit Copilot.
Nur eben halt die Standalone-Versionen machen da ziemlich Stress.
So.
Jetzt läuft hier aber alles.
Und wir fangen mal mit Word an.
Dass Copilot aktiv ist, seht ihr, wenn unter Start rechts so ein blaues Copilot-Icon zu
sehen ist.
Und zusätzlich, wenn ihr ein neues Dokument in Word anfangt, ist so ein kleineres Copilot-Icon
neben dem Cursor.
Könnt ihr dann direkt nutzen, um Text zu generieren.
Also ich tipp hier mal ein, schreib ein Gedicht.
Copilot fängt dann an, direkt in Word irgendwas reinzuschreiben.
Ein ungewöhnlicher Mix.
Ich habe einen Raspberry Pi.
Ein kleiner Computer ist er.
Er kann viel mehr als nur schreiben.
Er kann spielen.
Er kann programmieren und lernen.
Er ist mein Raspberry Pi.
Er ist mein kluger Helfer.
Hat er nicht geschrieben, dass ich das reimen soll?
Könnt ihr dann direkt nutzen, um Text zu generieren.
Also ich tipp hier mal ein, schreib ein Gedicht.
Ein sich reimendes Gedicht über Raspberry Pi.
Ja.
Ich schreib ein Gedicht.
Copilot fängt dann an, direkt in Word irgendwas reinzuschreiben.
Entweder erkenne ich die Reime nicht.
Vielleicht reimt sich es auf Englisch und er hat es auf Deutsch übersetzt dann.
Mit einer Überschrift, mit größerem Text.
Also es gibt auch automatische Funktionen.
Er ist.
Er ist mein Martin.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich habe ein Stück Schokolade.
Ein süßer.
Das reimt sich überhaupt nicht.
Formatierung.
Nice.
Man kann dann in diesem Feld hier auch Änderungswünsche reinschreiben.
Und dann anschließend hiermit zwischen den unterschiedlichen Varianten hin- und herschalten.
Da hat sich Microsoft ziemlich offensichtlich von Adobe Photoshop inspirieren lassen.
Da sieht dieser KI-Balken nämlich fast genauso aus und funktioniert auch so.
Naja.
Leider ist inhaltlich das Ganze oft nicht so, wie man das haben will.
Hier habe ich zum Beispiel gesagt, dass ich das Gedicht reimen soll.
Und ja, da reimt sich, auch nachdem ich das gedickt habe, gar nicht.
Und hier, als ich das dann nochmal probiert habe, gibt es zumindest ein paar Reime.
Mein Magen ist angeschlagen.
Okay.
Ja.
Aber so wirklich einer Logik folgt das ja auch nicht.
Magen angeschlagen.
Kakaobaum Traum.
Aber Goethe ist das nicht.
Sobald man dann beibehalten geklickt hat, sind die einzelnen Textfassungen zum Durchklicken dann auch weg.
Wenn man den Block wieder markiert und dann aufs Copilot-Icon geht, gibt es nur die Möglichkeiten umschreiben und als Tabelle visualisieren.
Ich kann also nicht mehr wie ganz am Anfang konkrete Wünsche eintippen, sondern einfach nur noch total unkonkret umschreiben lassen.
Ah, dann merkt sich also nicht die Verknüpfung zu Chat-GPT von diesem Text, sondern es ist danach einfach normaler Text in Word.
Wie ich das dann gemacht habe.
Ja, auch unsinnige Integration, irgendwie so halbherzig.
Das dauert dann ein bisschen.
Danach kann ich dann nochmal zwischen neutral, professionell, informell, prägnant und phantasievoll wählen.
Und das geht dann aber oft nicht, wenn ich da so einen Begriff angeklickt habe.
Da kommt dann so eine Fehlermeldung.
Probiert man exakt das gleiche nochmal, dann geht es dann manchmal doch.
Beziehungsweise so halb.
Also hier hat er ja erst...
Ja, das ist was, was mir bei Windows generell allgemein auf den Sack geht.
Dass viele Sachen manchmal einfach nicht machen und dann doch und man weiß nicht warum.
Nach dem halben Text abgebrochen.
Aber das hat sich wirklich durch unsere Tests gezogen, dass Word ständig in...
Soll ja keiner sehen, dass du Chat-GPT verwendest.
Nein, wenn du es am Ende speicherst als PDF oder so, dann kann das alles weg sein.
Aber in meinem Word-Dokument ist doch nicht verkehrt, dass er sich merkt, dass das ein GPT generated ist.
Dass ich dann das im Nachhinein auch modifizieren kann.
Wenn es danach einfach nach einmal generieren Text ist und ich möchte es nachher ändern.
Das ist Kacke.
Das ist schlechte Integration.
Was ich nicht machen wollte.
Richtig absurd ist dieses als Tabelle visualisieren.
Also das mag Fälle geben, in denen das sinnvoll ist.
Aber oft weigert sich Copilot auch einfach, wenn man das klickt oder es kommt sowas raus.
Das ist der Absatz, den ich hier gerade erzählt habe.
Feature Copilot, Feature umschreiben, Vorteile, Nachteile.
Hä?
Also das ergibt einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja und wenn man nicht mit dem Text so direkt interagieren will,
kann man statt dem Icon im Textfeld auch hier oben auf das große Copilot-Icon klicken.
Dann klappt sich das hier so recht.
Ich wüsste wirklich nicht, wozu ich das benutzen sollte.
Weil warum ist es besser, wenn das in Word integriert ist,
anstatt dass ich über Chat-GPT selbst, über das Web-Interface,
was generaten lasse und das dann in Word rein copy-paste.
Ich sehe da wirklich noch keinen großen Mehrwert.
Bei PowerPoint vielleicht, ja, aber bei Word bis jetzt nicht.
Und dann kann man eher so ganz...
Wegen 22 Euro, ja.
Das ist der Mehrwert für Microsoft.
...heitlich mit dem Text interagieren.
Also hier habe ich zum Beispiel mal dieses Skript zusammenfassen lassen.
Ja, und es dauert, wie gesagt.
Und dann kann man während Copilot da rechts rumrödelt,
links zumindest weiterarbeiten.
Aber zuverlässig arbeitet dieser Ausklapp Copilot auch nicht.
Zum Beispiel sagt er hier irgendwas von einer Verlosung.
Das steht aber gar nicht im Text.
Das war in einer ganz alten Fassung,
die ich vor ewiger Zeit gelöscht habe.
Ja, war geil.
Wirft man mit copy-paste irgendwas ins Text,
falls irgendwas ins Text fällt
und will sofort die Textzusammenfassung haben,
geht das oft auch nicht.
Man muss dann erst unbestimmte Zeit warten,
bis Copilot den Text, ja, weiß ich nicht, registriert.
Keine Ahnung.
Was man mit diesem Ausklapp Copilot aufmachen können soll...
Also, mal zusammengefasst.
Schrott.
... Änderungen am Text.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich eingebe,
mach mal immer die Zahl 3003 in FET,
dann kommt da nur so ein komischer halbenglischer Mischmasch,
wie man Word selbst dazu bringt, das zu tun.
Also eher so eine Karl-Klammer-mäßige Hilfe-Funktion.
Dabei will man ja natürlich,
dass der Copilot die Sachen selbst umsetzt.
Aber das klappt wirklich nur sehr selten.
Das doofe ist auch, dass man halt nicht weiß,
kann der das jetzt generell nicht
oder prompte ich nur ungenau
und muss das anders formulieren.
Was zumindest gut klappt,
wenn man sehr schlampig formuliert,
also sowas wie,
dann ist die Frau da in dieses Geschäft gegangen
und hat da rumgeguckt und dann hat sie ein Gürtel gekauft,
da hat sie an ihren Bruder erinnert,
als sie drei Jahre alt war
und dann war sie ein bisschen traurig
und dann hat sie sich einen Kuchen gekauft,
weil das hilft manchmal,
wenn man traurig ist wegen Zucker
und dann ging es schon wieder
und dann ist sie mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit gefahren
mit Fahrstuhl.
Also stilistisch würde ich sagen,
ist das schlecht.
Da habe ich dann einfach in der Seitenleiste gebeten,
schreibt das so um,
dass es sich literarischer liest
und ja, das funktioniert.
Die Frau betrat das Geschäft
und ließ ihren Blick schweifen.
Also definitiv besser,
aber das hätte man auch kostenlos haben können
mit ChatGPT oder Bing Chat
oder Google Gemini.
Also irgendwas umschreiben
geht damit copy-paste-mäßig sehr problemlos.
Was aber wirklich nur mit Copilot geht,
automatische Präsentation mit PowerPoint.
Ich habe hier im Word Copilot gesagt,
kannst du aus dem Text mit der Frau
eine Präsentation machen?
Und dann gab es so eine Textzusammenfassung,
was auf den einzelnen Folien zu sehen sein soll.
Leider arbeitet der Copilot aber nicht softwareübergreifend.
Das heißt, man muss erst PowerPoint starten
und dann im PowerPoint Copilot sagen,
erstelle eine Präsentation
und dann den von Word Copilot erstellten Text da reinpasten.
Da kommt dann das hier raus.
Die Geschichte.
Einer Frau.
Gürtelkauf.
Kuchengenuss.
Fahrradfahrt.
Aber das ist ja wirklich einigermaßen beeindruckend,
weil das wirklich aussieht wie so eine echte,
handgemachte PowerPoint-Präsentation.
Die Bilder hat sich der Copilot übrigens aus der PowerPoint...
Gut, ich meine für schwachsinnige Aufgaben
kann der Copilot ja nichts.
Schwachsinn in, Schwachsinn out.
Ja und ich habe dann etliche solcher Präsentationen machen lassen.
Zum Beispiel eine mit den seltsamsten
und ungewöhnlichsten Attraktionen in Hannover.
Am Ende waren das aber leider einfach die Standard-Touristen-Attraktionen.
Vor allem haben aber die Bilder mal so gar nicht gepasst.
Also das Luftbild auf der Startfolie war okay.
Das ist wirklich Hannover.
Aber alle anderen weiß ich auch nicht, was das sein soll.
Ich habe das gleiche mal mit New York City versucht.
Da ist Microsoft ja auch geografisch näher dran.
Und ja, die Attraktionen sind auf jeden Fall ungewöhnlicher.
Aber a existieren einige davon nicht oder nicht mehr.
Zum Beispiel das KGB-Museum.
Und b sind auch hier
die Bilder völlig falsch.
Also der Leuchtturm von Jeffreys Hook
sieht nicht so aus, sondern so.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich diese Funktion
eigentlich theoretisch praktisch finde,
weil ich manchmal PowerPoint-Präsentationen bauen muss
und mir das wenig Spaß macht.
Ich denke eher in Text als in Bild
und würde das deshalb gut finden, wenn ich das so...
Also so automatisches irgendwie Bildfinden dazu und so,
das stelle ich mir schon ganz nützlich vor.
...Präsentation sagen will,
in Word aufschreibe und der Copilot
macht mir da dann eine Präse draus.
Mit Bildern und allem.
Nur leider war das bei unseren Tests oft so unzuverlässig,
dass es zumindest für mich noch keinen Sinn ergibt.
Ich habe zum Beispiel das Skript von diesem Video
hier mal als Präsentation zusammenfassen lassen.
Und das sieht dann so aus.
Also erstmal ist da jegliche Kritik nicht mehr da,
die ja zweifellos in diesem Skript drinsteckt.
Und da stehen auch Sachen drin,
die ich definitiv da nicht reingeschrieben habe.
Also die KI kann dabei helfen,
barrierefreie Dokumente zu erstellen?
Habe ich nicht geschrieben.
Das ist auf monatlicher und jährlicher Basis verfügbar.
Das mag stimmen, aber das steht nicht im Skript.
Und generell ist diese Präsentation so oberflächlich,
die hat null mit meinem Text zu tun.
Aber vielleicht rechtfertigt ja Excel die 22 Euro im Monat.
Spoiler, nein.
Das Ding ist erstmal komplett Englisch,
man kann also nicht in Deutsch prompten.
Und es spuckte bei mir einfach immer nur Fehlermeldungen aus.
Das einzige, was ich hinbekommen habe,
diese Tabelle hier grafisch umzugestalten.
Was sind...
Was sind 5 BS?
Aber sonst leider gar nichts.
Und Excel wäre jetzt das,
wo ich mir eine KI wünschen würde,
weil ich bin kein Excel-Profi
und da sehr oft an meine Grenzen stoße.
Ich würde da gerne einfach sagen,
addiere mal bitte alle Zahlen hier,
rechne das dann von Dollar an Euro um
und schreib mir da das Ergebnis hin.
Aber leider klappt das eben noch nicht.
Apropos klappt ihr nicht,
auch in Outlook soll der Copilot Pro helfen,
nämlich Mails zusammenfassen.
Aber bei mir fehlte da einfach immer der Copilot-Button.
Mein Fazit.
Ganz ehrlich,
Copilot Pro für Office ist
in der aktuellen Fassung
eine Frechheit.
Wir sprechen ja nicht von einem kleinen Start-Up,
was ein bisschen mit KI frickelt,
sondern wir sprechen hier von einem der größten Unternehmen der Welt,
das ein Produkt für 22 Euro im Monat verkauft,
das bestenfalls
eine frühe Beta ist.
Angefangen bei den Problemen,
die auftreten, wenn man ein berufliches Microsoft-Konto nutzt,
bis hin zu dem komischen
Nachmischmarsch und natürlich
den vielen inhaltlichen Fehlern,
die der Copilot macht.
Und natürlich, klar,
aktuelle KI-Technik mit großen Sprachmodellen
neigt grundsätzlich zu Halluzinationen.
Aber es ist technisch auf jeden Fall auch heute schon möglich,
einen Text zusammenzufassen,
ohne da irgendwelche Inhalte reinzuhalluzinieren,
die da nicht drinstehen.
Das geht.
Also das Produkt, was Stand heute existiert,
ist meines Erachtens noch nicht sinnvoll zu gebrauchen.
Bzw. kann man die sinnvollen Dinge
aus großen Angeboten hinbekommen,
z.B. einen schlecht formulierten Text umschreiben lassen.
Aber in der Idee,
Office über KI zu nutzen,
steckt auch viel Potenzial.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Gerade Powerpoint stelle ich mir wirklich spannend vor,
wenn das mal gescheit funktioniert.
Weil niemand hat Bock
da drauf,
die Präsentation
hübsch zu machen und sowas.
Also gerade
das automatische Bildersuchen
zu einem Text und so stelle ich mir praktisch vor.
Dazu brauchst du nicht die 22 Euro im Monat Funktion.
Text in Word
eine Powerpoint Präsentation
machen zu können,
oder Excel mit natürlicher Sprache
statt mit Formeln zu bedienen.
Ich traue Microsoft das zu,
dass sie das irgendwann hinbekommen
und dann können sie von mir aus auch fürs Abo kassieren.
Aber heute finde ich es echt schwierig.
Und auch wenn ich einige Dinge durchaus praktisch finde,
ist diese Welle
der KI generierten Inhalte
natürlich auch ziemlich problematisch.
Also ich bin froh, dass ich kein Lehrer bin.
Also die einzige generierte Powerpoint Präsentation,
die inhaltlich nicht total doof war,
war eine typische Schulaufgabe.
Erstelle eine Präsentation
über die Figur des Tambour-Major
in Woizek. Das war okay.
Und ja, könnte man sich vorstellen,
dass Schülerinnen und Schüler das wohl auch mal nutzen.
Ja also was passiert jetzt eigentlich,
wenn diese KI Sachen einfach Standard
Ich finde das auch gar nicht schlimm, wenn die das benutzen.
Die müssen dann aber lernen,
das ist dann wahrscheinlich das Wichtige
dabei, die müssen aber lernen,
dass das als
ihre Präsentation gilt.
Also wenn da was halluziniert wird
und Bullshit drinnen steht, dann steht da halt Bullshit drinnen.
Und man kann sich danach nicht rausreden
mit, ah das hat doch Chat-GPT generiert.
Du bist verantwortlich für das, was du abgibst.
Und wenn Chat-GPT Scheiße generiert, bist du dafür
halt, hast du gelitten.
Das heißt, du musst dich trotzdem mit dem Thema
auseinandersetzen und am Ende gucken,
ob das alles stimmt.
Und du musst dich mit dem Thema
ordentlich auseinandergesetzt haben,
dass du überhaupt ansatzweise einschätzen kannst,
was Chat-GPT macht,
sinnvoll ist.
Texte und Bilder überall,
das wird bestimmt nicht besser in Zukunft
und das Datenschutz-Fass
mach ich mal gar nicht auf. Aber wer weiß,
vielleicht gibt es ja auch eine Renaissance
des handgemachten Textes
und Bildes. Wie seht ihr das?
Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben
und natürlich diesen Chat
Also ich glaube,
das braucht noch ein bisschen.
Aber wir haben die Entwicklung
der letzten Jahre über gesehen, da tut sich schon
enorm viel.
Wo ich ja persönlich ein bisschen gespannt drauf bin,
ist die ganze Video-Generating
Video-Generation-Geschichte.
Wieso, wer ist das?
Herr Arnus?
Was für ein Name, Alter.
In der Mail kam
Ja, da sind die halt selbst dran schuld,
wenn die was ungefragt übernehmen.
Shit happens.
Du bist dafür
verantwortlich,
was du da einreichst.
Ich kann sich nicht damit rausreden.
Chat-GPT hat das generiert.
Can we have this?
Nein, können wir nicht.
Mal gucken, ob Youtube mittlerweile gelernt hat.
Oh nein!
Fuck, ich habe Weeb-Musik gehört, Leute!
Jetzt denkt Youtube,
ich möchte
Anime-Songs hören.
Okay,
was ist Sora?
Wollen wir uns Fire-Ship angucken?
Der hat mir so viel Schrott
empfohlen, Mann. Schade, dass er nicht da ist.
Ich glaube, dass Youtube die History,
die Watch-History irgendwie verpeilt hat.
Ach, das ist der Video-Generator.
Ja, da bin ich, da bin ich echt gespannt drauf.
Lasst uns das mal angucken.
Okay.
Ja, das habe ich gesehen.
Das habe ich gesehen mit der Katze.
Das mit der Katze habe ich gesehen.
Das...
Ja, das habe ich gesehen.
Das habe ich gesehen mit der Katze.
Das mit der Katze habe ich gesehen.
Das...
Mhm.
Ja.
allons.
Doctors
with
z 얏
f
10 million tokens that was an incredible achievement that was also blowing people's minds but sundar was
quickly overshadowed by sam altman who just gave us a preview of his new friend sora which comes
from the japanese word for sky it's a text-to-video model and all the video clips you're seeing in this
video have been generated by sora it's not the first ai video model we already have open models
like stable video diffusion and private products like pika but sora blows everything out of the
water not only are the images more realistic but they can be up to a minute long and maintain
cohesion between frames they can also be rendered in different aspect ratios they can either be
created from a test that's it's from nice prompt where you describe what you want to see or from
a starting image that gets brought to life now my initial thought was that openai cherry picked all
these examples but it appears that's not the case because sam altman was taking requests from the
crowd on twitter and returning examples within a few minutes like two golden retrievers doing
a podcast on top of a mountain not bad but this next one's really impressive a guy turning a
non-profit open source company into a profit-making closed source company
in fact sam altman is also a non-profit open source company and he is also a non-profit open source company
impressive very nice so now you might be wondering how you can get your hands on this
thing well not so fast if a model this powerful youtube shorts wird komplett voll sein given to
some random chud one can only imagine the horrors that it would be used for it would be nice if we
could generate video for our ai influencers for additional tips but that's never going to happen
it's highly unlikely this model will ever be open source and when they do release it videos will
have c2pa metadata which is basically a surveillance apparatus that keeps a record of where
content came from and how it was modified in any case we do have some details on how the model
works it likely takes a massive amount of computing power and just a couple weeks ago
sam altman asked the world for seven trillion dollars so you buy a bunch of gpus yeah that's
trillion with a t and yeah can we don't want to
army trillions this gleiche wie europäische trillions
weil army billions sind nicht das gleiche wie unsere billions
and even jensen wong made fun of that number because it should really only cost around 2
trillion dollars to get that job done but maybe jensen is wong it's going to take a lot of gpus for
video models to scale let's find out how they work sora is a diffusion model like dolly and
stable diffusion where you start with some random noise then gradually update that noise to a
coherent image check out this video if you want to learn more about that algorithm now there's a ton
of data in a single still image like a thousand pixels by a thousand pixels by three color
channels comes out to three million data points that's a big number but what if we have a one
minute video at 60 frames per second now we have over 10 billion data points to generate
now just to put that in perspective for the primate brain one million seconds is about a
hundred and a half days while 10 billion seconds is about 317 years so there's a massive
difference in scale plus video has the added dimension of time to understand this data they
took an approach similar to large language models which tokenize text like code and poetry for
example however text but rather visual patches these are like small compressed chunks of images
that capture both what they are visually and how they move through time or frame by frame what's
also interesting is that video models typically crop their training data and outputs to a
specific time and resolution but sora can train data on its native resolution and output variable
resolutions as well that's pretty that's pretty cool so how is this technology going to change
the world well last year tools like photoshop got a whole suite of ai editing tools in the future
we'll be able to do the same in video like you might have a car driving down the road and want
to change the background scenery now you can do that in 10 seconds instead of hiring a cameraman
and cgi expert but another lucrative high paying career that's been put on notice is minecraft
can simulate artificial movement in minecraft and potentially turn any idea into a minecraft
world in seconds or maybe you want to direct your own indie pixar movie ai makes that possible by
stealing the artwork of talented humans but it might not be that easy as impressive as these
videos are you'll notice a lot of flaws if you look closely they have that subtle but distinctive
ai look about them and they don't perfectly model physics or humanoid interactions but it's only a
matter of time before these limitations are figured out although i'm personally threatened and terror
ich frage mich wie es mit schrift aussieht mit schrift hat das ja alles immer probleme
it's been a privilege and an honor to watch 10 000 years of human culture get devoured by robots
this has been the code report thanks for watching and i will see you in the next one also mit
schrift hat sich das ja immer schwer getan schrift und finger also finger ist mir nie
groß aufgefallen aber schrift und was mir bei bildern aufgefallen ist die haben immer so einen
leichten gerade bei bei haut und so das hat so einen leichten glanz plastik look oftmals so
was haben wir denn sonst hier noch baupläne prüfen boah da hätte ich ja ey so office und
bürokratische sachen gehen mir eh schon auf den sack aber das wäre ja auf jeden fall nicht der
job für mich man baupläne prüfen das verdienen beamte moment das verdienen beamte in der
verwaltung okay warum ist die bewertung so schlecht die muss enorm viel verdienen für
bürokratischen wahrscheinlich was ist da los jaylor das ist auch geil
finger anziehen dass man echt das video für er generiert hält das ist man next level high
IQ shit quasi real life g-baiting okay zeig mal her baupläne prüfen boah das klingt schon
so langweilig wenn ich das den ganzen tag machen müsste ich arbeite im büro und bearbeite anträge
bearbeite anträge ja das hätte ich gedacht ich habe ja schon mit meiner berufswahl auch
ein gewisses einkommensspektrum mit gebucht wo ich weiß da eben gibt's ja auch ein gewisses einkommen
spektrum mit gebucht wo ich weiß da eben gibt's ja auch ein gewisses einkommensspektrum mit gebucht
wo ich weiß da eben gibt's ja auch ein gewisses einkommensspektrum mit gebucht wo ich weiß da eben gibt's
einfach nicht mehr entwicklungsmöglichkeiten nach oben
hi ich bin da medianer 33 jahre alt und arbeite als verwaltungsbeamtin im Gallery
ohrringe sehen irgendwie als generated aus oder sicher dass das ein echtes video
ist bereich baurecht hier in tsch gin
im fibre
liquid
hallo
Ich sage allen Hallo, außer die, die ich nicht mag.
Verwaltungsbeamtin im Bereich Bauer.
Also ich sage morgens nicht allen Hallo. Ich sage vielleicht Hallo, wenn jemand mit mir über den Weg laufe.
Ansonsten gehe ich schnell ins Büro rein, mache die Tür zu und hoffe, dass mich wirklich lang keiner anspricht.
Ich prüfe zum Beispiel verschiedene Anträge, die bei uns eingehen.
Ich nehme Beschwerden entgegen, prüfe illegale Bauten.
Ich habe selber früher nie damit gerechnet, dass ich mal hier lande.
Ob da auch Quality Destiny ist?
Weil mir das alles viel zu langweilig vorkam, dass das eigentlich was ist, was unsere Gesellschaft mitträgt
und wo man tatsächlich an ganz lebensnahen Themen dran ist.
Das habe ich halt nie bedacht und das ist eine ganz große Motivation.
Da muss ich jetzt, wenn ich das sehe, an der Stelle mal erzählen.
Also wusstet ihr, dass man Geld bezahlen muss, wenn man zu viel Schatten auf das Nachbargrundstück wirft?
Also das regeln dann so Leute hier.
Und es ist nicht etwa so,
dass du das Geld bezahlen musst,
dass du das Geld an den Nachbar bezahlen musst.
Nein, nein, nein, du musst das als Strafe ans Amt bezahlen.
Nicht etwa an den Nachbar, wo du zu viel Schatten drauf wirfst.
Das wäre ja viel zu naheliegend.
Und noch was Zweites, auch witzige Sachen mit so bürokratischen Dingern.
Wir haben letztens einen Baum fällen lassen im Garten.
Da hat man ein bisschen Bedenken gehabt, dass das wackelig wird.
Und wenn man Pech hat, so zum Nachbar rüber fällt.
Baum fällen lassen.
Und dann ein paar Monate später von einer Baumzerlegungsfirma den Baum kleinschneiden lassen und häckseln und abtransportieren lassen.
Und wisst ihr was war?
An dem Tag, wo diese Firma da war, die den, also eigentlich war das nur, eigentlich war das, das war nur ein Typ.
Ein Typ war da und hat das gemacht.
An dem Tag, wo der gekommen ist und hat unseren Baum gehäckselt und kleingemacht und zersägt und abtransportiert.
Auf einmal stand einer vom Ordnungsamt vor der Tür.
Und hat geklingelt.
Und hat gesagt, what?
Was willst du so?
Was ist hier?
Und dann hat er gesagt, ja.
Er hat einen anonymen Hinweis erhalten.
Wir würden illegalerweise Bäume fällen.
Musst du dir mal vorstellen.
Da hat irgendeiner, irgendeiner der Nachbarn von drumherum zu viel Zeit.
Hat von seinem Balkon geguckt.
Und hat gesehen, die schneiden da an einem Baum rum.
Im Garten.
Ich ruf jetzt beim Ordnungsamt an und schwärz die an.
War natürlich nix.
Weil das war genehmigt.
Und der Baum wurde ja schon in Zeiten gefällt, wo das noch erlaubt war.
Ja.
Geil, ne?
Auch für meine Arbeit.
Ute.
Was? Ich hab es nicht verstanden.
Dass man da an Themen dran ist.
Große Motivation, dass man da an Themen dran ist.
Das hab ich halt nie bedacht.
Und das ist eine ganz große Motivation.
Gleich kommt Ute.
Für meine Arbeit.
Ute.
Ging es da jetzt nur um diese Beschwerde?
Oder um noch mehr?
Ja, die Thematik ist, dass gegenüber von diesem Wohnhaus sich eine Verladestation befindet.
Wo Holz umgeschlagen wird.
Also Holzstapel.
Dann sind da Hackschnitzel, Berge.
Wo öfter mal was passiert.
Hackschnitzel?
Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Die Straße legt dann diese Abfahrt
und Zufahrtsverkehr durch die LKW.
Und das müssen wir jetzt halt prüfen,
was da wie genehmigt ist
und wie begründet die Beschwerde ist.
Okay, es ist auf jeden Fall Outlook,
was die hier am Start haben.
Ich guck dann auch immer online.
Bestimmt, ja, bestimmt auch Outlook.
Und was sieht man da noch?
Keine Ahnung. PDF?
Nextcloud? Ne, ich erkenne es nicht.
Noch in unserer...
Ich wundere mich, wenn die freiwillig
Nextcloud verwenden.
Infoportal.
Da habe ich Einblick in
die ganzen Grundstücke.
Was steht heute auf dem Speiseplan?
Ihr kommt nie drauf.
Kann mir anzeigen lassen, wem gehören die...
Ich versuche jetzt nochmal die Gemeinde...
War da ein Shitrix-Logo?
Wo war da ein Shitrix-Logo?
Die ganzen Grundstücke und so weiter.
Kann mir anzeigen lassen, wem gehören die...
Shitrix? Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Ich versuche jetzt nochmal die Gemeinde zu erreichen.
Ob ich da noch was in Erfahrung bringen kann
für die Besprechungen nachher.
Klantratsamt Schwäbischalb.
Boah, da hätte ich so keinen Bock.
Das ist, glaube ich, eines der schrecklichsten Jobs,
die ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Das Ganze wird nur noch getoppt von Grundschullehrer
oder so was. Oder generell von...
Muss ja nicht mal Grundschullehrer sein.
Da sind sie ja wenigstens noch halbwegs umgänglich
von Lehrer. Lehrer ist, glaube ich,
der schrecklichste Job. Und so was wäre
der zweitschrecklichste Job, den ich mir vorstellen kann.
Hallo, Herr Christ. Mir liegt da jetzt nur
ein Bauvorbescheid vor
und keine... Oh nein!
Fuck! Alter!
Nur ein Bauvorbescheid. Jetzt vorbei.
Wissen Sie da was?
Das ist nicht Teams.
Das ist irgendwas Selbstgestricktes.
Ist das noch Skype?
For Business? Nee, sieht nicht so aus.
Was ist denn das? Hat irgendjemand
einen Plan, was das für ein Chat-Voice-Dings-Programm ist?
Was?
Was für ein Ding?
Was ist Swix?
Hört sich unanständig an.
Telekom.
Aber zumindest ordentliche Ausstattung.
Guck mal hier. Ein Tablet am Start.
Zwei Bildschirme. Da kann man übrigens gescheit arbeiten.
Was ist Swix, Alter?
Swix. Das hört sich übelst
unanständig an.
Sip?
Vielleicht.
Gut, dann danke ich Ihnen für die Auskünfte.
Ja, danke.
Nee, Jabber glaube ich nicht.
Ja, tschüss.
Warum sagt die Tschüss und nicht Cu?
Also der Beschwerdeführer wohnt auch tatsächlich selber drin.
Das bedeutet, dass derjenige, der sich beschwert hat,
auch einen Grund hätte, sich zu beschweren,
weil er da rechtmäßig wohnt.
Wäre es jetzt so gewesen,
dass da Wohnen überhaupt nicht zulässig ist,
dann hätte er auch keine Abwehransprüche
gegen das, was irgendwo passiert,
weil er quasi illegal da ist.
Aber so wie es aussieht, darf er da ja auch wohnen.
Ja.
Und dann müssen wir uns das im Detail anschauen,
was da für Schwierigkeiten bestehen
mit der Nachbarschaft.
Wenn man das sieht,
ist es alles kein Wunder.
Ich will den Leuten mal gar nicht absprechen,
dass sie das ernst nehmen und sich Mühe geben.
Ich glaube, da gibt es tatsächlich einen...
Der Anteil ist größer, als man so denkt.
Aber es ist alles kein Wunder.
Es dauert alles so lang und so ewig
und so undurchsichtig.
So nervig alles.
Sicherheit Holzstapel.
Wollen wir nicht in 50 Milliarden?
Wenn man mit Bautechnik auswärts macht,
wenn es statisch ein Thema von denen ist,
dann haben wir ja diese Stapel.
Moment, die besprechen jetzt erst, welche Abteilung zuständig ist.
Es ist nicht etwa so, dass da jetzt was passiert.
Ja?
Sie besprechen, welche Abteilung für den Fall zuständig ist.
Da kommt jetzt noch nichts raus.
Vielleicht statisch
ein Thema von denen ist.
Dann haben wir ja diese Stapel.
Warum tippst du immer in das Urlfeld ein?
Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn.
Nur mit so ein paar Holzpaletten
hier vorne gesichert.
Ja, das sieht nicht so vertrauenserweckend aus.
Was dazu die Frage ist, ist das dann euer Thema?
Also grundsätzlich sehe ich uns zuständig an.
Ja.
Oh, Bürokratie, Mann!
Wiederführen wird es jetzt beim Emissionsschutz laufen
und ich beauftrage unseren Baukontrolleur,
dass er sich die Sache vor Ort mal anguckt,
was die Statik und die Sicherheit
von den Stapeln und so angeht.
Am herausforderndsten
Es geht um den Krach, Mann!
sind Momente, in denen
Leute anrufen,
die sich durch
die Entscheidungen von mir,
also die auch von mir unterschrieben sind zum Beispiel,
irgendwie angegriffen
fühlen und
Ja, das kommt wahrscheinlich öfters vor.
und dann auch entsprechend Luft machen
und es dann eher so auf die persönliche Ebene
geht, dass
meine Kompetenz infrage gestellt wird.
Was zu meinem Job halt auch dazu gehört,
ist immer alles gut zu dokumentieren
und alles. Boah, ey, das wäre so abfuck,
dieser Job, Mann! Alter, habe ich da
keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist in unserem Verfahren abzulegen.
Das nimmt dann auch meistens so ein bisschen
Zeit in Anspruch, die ganzen E-Mails dann
da abzulegen und so.
Mahlzeit, bis später!
Ja weh, das hat nicht das richtige Aktzeichen, Mann!
Also von Anfang an lernt man dann
zur Mittagszeit Mahlzeit zu sagen
Oh, ey, Leute, das triggert mich
auch immer. Wenn du auf dem Weg zur
Kantine bist und gefühlt
50 Mal
dann die Leute ankommen
mit guten Hunger, Mahlzeit,
lasst es euch schmecken!
Oh, Mann! Deswegen gehe ich
dann, also es gibt zwei
Gründen, warum ich nicht zur Kantine gehe.
Das erste ist, weil ich das meistens nicht
so gut vertrage, generell vieles, vieles,
was es da in Frankfurt zum Mittag gibt.
Und zweitens, weil man so viele Leute sieht
auf dem Weg, Mann.
Das muss pünktlich, 11 Uhr
59, Mann!
Muss das sein?
Ja, am meisten Geld geben wir
klar für Wohnen und Essen
aus.
Ja, einen heißen
Sanddorn, bitte.
Einen heißen
Sanddorn? Was?
Und das muss ich jetzt mal
heißer Sand
Dorn?
Das ist ein Saft, davon wird man doch nicht
satt.
Ich arbeite 70 Prozent, das bedeutet 28
Sehr gute Wahl, sehr gute Wahl.
7 Stunden die Woche
und diese Stunden verteilen sich auf
fünf Tage, Montag bis Freitag
an
Ja, jeder wie er Bock hat.
Aber das ist schon mal gut.
Drei Vormittagen und zweimal den ganzen Tag.
Das hier ist jetzt auch
ein Bereich, für den ich zuständig
bin. Für diese Gemeinden gehen auch
die ganzen Baulasten
bei mir ein. Das hier ist jetzt
zum Beispiel ein Doppelhaus.
Boah, dieser ganze Papierkrieg.
Ich würde es so durchdrehen.
Bei verschiedenen Grundstücken ist es so, dass man so viel Geld braucht.
Und mit der Baulast wird erklärt,
dass die zwei Grundstücke als
ein Grundstück
anzuerkennen sind, im baurechtlichen
Sinn. Das kommt dann zu mir. Ich prüfe
das nochmal und schicke es dann an die Gemeinde
zurück, damit die es in ihr Baulastenverzeichnis
aufnehmen können.
Was natürlich schon gut ist.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass
man dort den Eindruck hat, dass man irgendwas
nennenswertes
geschafft hat am Ende des Tages.
Muss man sich bestimmt dran gewöhnen.
Ich meine, bei uns geht mir das mit Bürokratie
schon auf den Sack.
Weil wir so viele Auflagen und Vorgaben haben.
Aber das ist ja nochmal
Level oben drüber.
Das Gefühl ist gerade, wenn ich so eine umfassendere
rechtliche Recherche zu einem Thema
habe, wenn ich da wie so einen Durchbruch
habe und dann plötzlich so klar sehe
und denke, ah, so und so könnte man das
in dem Fall lösen. Im besten
Fall natürlich dann auch, wenn
es sich positiv für die
antragstellende Person auswirkt.
Das ist ja auch das, für was wir
da sind, dass wir auch Sachen möglich machen.
Könnte auch für dich noch reichen.
Das
schätze ich ja allgemein im Amt sehr,
dass man auch mit den unterschiedlichen Fachbereichen
Zumindest macht's
einen recht gechillten Eindruck, oder?
So zwischen Tür und Angel auch gut kommunizieren kann.
Kriegt man halt auch mal Fälle mit, die man jetzt so
im normalen Verfahrensablauf
vielleicht nicht so zu Gesicht bekommt.
Als erstes
habe ich Kunsttherapie studiert, habe das
zu Ende gebracht. Danach aber direkt
Was?
Okay, Leute,
Kunsttherapie. Anhand des
Namens hätte ich absolut null Plan,
was es überhaupt sein soll.
Public Management,
Jugendamt
und dann
Bau- und Umweltamt.
Umgeswitcht
zu dem Public Management Studium.
Danach
habe ich dann
Soll aber auch nicht ohne 8 Jahre studieren,
oder? Von 2011
bis 2019?
Jugendamt gearbeitet,
im Fachbereich Beistandschaften
und im Anschluss hier im Bau- und Umweltamt
noch einen Abstecher in die Wasserwirtschaft
gemacht, bevor ich dann hier im Baurecht
gelandet bin. Da drüben auf der anderen
Seite vom Berg wohnen.
Was ist Public Management?
Wohne ich übrigens.
Da denke ich öfter dran,
wenn ich hier dann so zurücklaufe.
Ich
verdiene brutto 3.185
Euro,
davon bleiben dann netto
2.668.
Die muss ja kaum Steuern bezahlen,
was ist das denn?
Wo muss die so wenig Steuern bezahlen?
Davon gehen dann noch
Krankenversicherungsbeiträge
und Pflegeversicherungsbeiträge weg
und das Darlehen.
Das ist nicht übel, ja, für 70%.
Für das E-Bike, wo wir dann
bei 2.346 Euro
komplett netto stehen.
Also wie viel kriegt sie jetzt überwiesen?
2.346 Euro.
Ja.
Geht doch, oder?
Ja,
ich würde sagen, für mich in meiner aktuellen
Lebenssituation
lohnt sich der Job.
Ich hätte natürlich noch ein paar Sachen,
die ich gerne anders hätte, also
die Wochenarbeitszeit bei einem Vollzeitjob
sind ja 41 Stunden.
Also da würde ich mir insgesamt eine Reduzierung
wünschen, die mehr an der
Lebensrealität von vielen
Menschen ist, nämlich das
mit der Arbeit auch noch andere
Verpflichtungen bestehen.
Meistens bin ich mit dem
E-Bike unterwegs, so in diesem
5 Kilometer Radius funktioniert das ziemlich gut.
Und das Auto
nutze ich natürlich vor allem
im Winter auch verstärkt.
Naja,
also seriously,
ich könnte mir das nicht vorstellen.
Das würde ich
nicht aushalten.
Das Bike hat knapp 2.800 Euro
gekostet. Das würde ich wirklich nicht aushalten.
Ich wohne zusammen mit
meiner Familie, also mit meinem Mann
und meinen zwei Kindern in
Aber das, ey, das könnte ich mir
echt nicht vorstellen.
E-Bike ist immer noch besser als
gar kein Bike.
Und je nachdem, was du für eine Strecke fährst,
schaffen es manche Leute auch gar nicht,
die Strecke mit dem normalen Fahrrad zu fahren.
Also ich finde das gar nicht schlecht,
die Entwicklung mit E-Bike.
Eigentlich ganz nice.
Ja, bei 5 Kilometern im Flachen braucht man
ein E-Bike, das stimmt schon.
5 Kilometer hast du nicht richtig angetreten,
da bist du schon da im Endeffekt.
Aber es ist praktisch.
Hast du studiert oder ein Abi?
Nein, weder das eine noch das andere tatsächlich.
Ich habe einen Realtorabschluss
gemacht, ich habe nicht studiert.
Ey, Leute, 5 Kilometer
berghoch geht natürlich richtig ab.
Das machst du nicht so einfach.
Richtig, ihr Gangster.
Selfmade.
Die Leute, die studieren gehen,
sind auch selfmade.
Es ist nicht so, als meldest du dich an
und kriegst dann instant deinen Abschluss.
Ab wie viel Prozent ist es berghoch?
Ein bisschen auf die Länge an.
Ah, 5 Prozent.
Ab 5 Prozent.
Würde ich sagen.
Und umso kürzer und umso steiler geht es natürlich.
Also ich weiß hier,
die eine Ecke hier,
da wo ich öfters wandern gehe,
da geht es ein Stück 27 Prozent hoch.
Super brutal.
Und wir haben hier die steilste Straße
in Hessen, haben wir auch hier um die Ecke.
Die ist, glaube ich, auch knapp 30 Prozent.
Aber da bin ich, da war ich noch nie.
Ich weiß nur, dass die hier in Gelnhausen um die Ecke ist.
Steilste Straße in Hessen.
Verdient man mehr Geld in der IT,
wenn man ein Studium hat, anstelle einer Ausbildung?
Ja, genau. Das ist das, was ich auch gerade sagen wollte.
Ja, im Durchschnitt, statistisch gesehen,
ja.
Das heißt nicht unbedingt, dass du persönlich,
wenn du was kannst,
was du auf dem Weg brauchbar verkaufen kannst,
zwangsläufig dann,
dass es bei dir auch weniger sein muss, ja.
Wenn du wie Max bist.
Du übertreibst zwar nicht so,
wie wir
Weeb-Musik empfohlen bekommen.
Quality is destiny, Leute.
Wir gucken das nicht nochmal.
Aber das ist die...
Das ist auch voll
verkackt, oder?
Ich hatte überhaupt keine Hoffnung
an Bones.
Ich hab mir nie gedacht so, ey...
Also erstens dachte ich gar nicht,
dass es überhaupt jemals rauskommt.
Und dann, wenn es rauskommt, dass es nix...
Wahrscheinlich, wenn ich mir den Titel so angucke,
ist das auch so.
Wie war das jetzt mit dem Essen?
Achso, jaja, heute gibt's Nudeln mit Lachs.
Schon wieder ein neues Cradle Bike.
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Gibt keinen Sinn meiner Größe.
Und auch nicht mit der Schaltung, die ich haben will.
Hast du schon mal was
von dem Wore-Out-Syndrom gehört?
Ja.
Wenn das quasi
ist, dass die Leute sich permanent
unterfordert fühlen auf der Arbeit
und deswegen dann teilweise sogar kündigen
oder Depressionen bekommen
und alles, ja. Hab ich schon.
Mich wundert's auch ehrlich gesagt
nicht, dass es sowas gibt.
Kannst du mal deine Karriere schildern
ab der Ausbildung? Okay.
Ab der Ausbildung ist easy.
Vor der Ausbildung kannst du nämlich knicken.
Ab der Ausbildung.
Die ist eigentlich ziemlich easy, meine
Karriere.
Wenn man das überhaupt so nennen kann.
Ich hab eine Ausbildung gemacht beim Internetprovider.
Hab danach noch ein Jahr gearbeitet oder
irgendwie so in dem Dreh
beim Internetprovider.
Dann bin ich gewechselt
zu einer
Bank in Frankfurt.
Die kannte ich schon, weil
dort war der Internetprovider als
Dienstleister tätig.
Und da gab's ein paar
lustige Ereignisse, wo ich euch ja schon ein paar mal
Sachen auf YouTube erzählt hab, zum Beispiel, dass
der Teamleiter,
also mein damaliger Teamleiter, hat Hausverbot
bekommen.
Wegen was weiß ich heute noch nicht.
Und die hatten echt Probleme mit dem
Laden.
Und irgendwann haben die dann gesagt, ey
wir haben keinen Bock mehr auf den Internetprovider,
aber wir haben Bock auf euch.
Dann hab ich gesagt, ja, ich hab auch Bock da drauf.
Gibt auch mehr Kohle. Also
let's go. Ich kannte den Laden schon
alles gut. Dann bin ich dahin
gewechselt und
ja, da hab ich
ein paar unterschiedliche Sachen gemacht.
Bis ich mich irgendwann
mal angefangen hab mit Serverautomatisierung
und
Sourcecodeverwaltung und sowas zu beschäftigen.
Einfach weil's mich interessiert hat.
Damals noch mit Puppet.
Dann über, über,
damals war Git ja noch der neue Scheiß.
Damals hat er noch gar keine Ahnung davon gehabt.
Und man nannte es damals auch nicht
DevOps, sondern es war einfach noch ganz
normal, so im Serveratmenbereich.
Hab ich damit angefangen
und das immer weiter ausgebaut
bei der alten Firma. Wir haben
zwischenzeitlich mit dem
Automatisierungssystem und alles haben wir über
4000 Server betreut.
Also die komplette Linux-Landschaft,
die wir hatten, über 4000 Systeme
zwischenzeitlich.
Also quasi mit dem Kram, den ich mir ausgedacht hab.
Ja, und da hab ich noch jede Menge andere
Sachen gemacht, aber zumindest
irgendwann sind die mir so sehr
auf den Keks gegangen mit ihren wirren
Abteilungen, vor allem mit ihrem dauerhaften
Zurückgerudere
und ihrem
mit ihrer Anti-Homeoffice
Einstellung, obwohl das wunderbar funktioniert
hat. Und das fast zum Überlaufen
gebracht hat, als ich mal einen Anschluss von
meinem Chef gekriegt hab, warum ich mich nicht
dran halten würde. Dabei hab ich mich dran gehalten.
Nämlich das, was wir ursprünglich
vereinbart haben, aber das wollten
sie ja dann nicht mehr.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, wisst ihr was, ihr könnt
mich mal. Und hab mich ein bisschen umgeguckt,
was es so gibt. Ich hätte
fast in Würzburg unterschrieben bei einem
Arbeitgeber, die haben mir aber dann garantiert
Homeoffice, außer halt zu irgendeinem Team-Event
einmal im Monat.
Und kurz bevor
ich dort unterschrieben
habe, ich hatte ja schon den Vertrag hier liegen,
kam noch ein ehemaliger
Kollege, den ich auch noch von der Bank damals kannte,
zu mir und hat gesagt, ey Max,
willst du nicht zu uns? Ich bin jetzt hier
bei einer Versicherung in Frankfurt, willst du
nicht zu uns? Wir suchen grad jemand
hier im Linux-Umfeld. Ja, nice, erzähl.
Und
da hab ich dem mal so zwischen
unter der Hand meine Bewerbungssachen
geschickt. Der hat es seinem Chef weitergegeben.
Sein Chef hat mich angerufen, da war ich
grad im Bauhaus Weihnachtsbaum kaufen, das weiß ich
noch. Und hab mich mit dem unterhalten,
das klang eigentlich alles ganz nice.
Und dann
haben wir ein paar Tage später
ein Vorstellungsgespräch, da haben wir uns
auch gleich gut verstanden und
haben auch gleich über Gehalt geredet
und die haben gemeint, ja, also
sie würden mich gerne ihr
Instant einstellen und hab gesagt, ja,
ich würde auch gerne bei euch anfangen,
aber wir müssen das jetzt halt schnell machen und ich
brauch halt irgendwas Handfestes, weil ich kann nicht dort
kündigen bei dem alten Laden, ohne dass
ich was sicher, was Neues hab, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Da haben die gesagt, ja, wir schicken ihnen
den Vertrag und so alles zu,
vorläufig schon per E-Mail und das ist
auch bindend, es sei denn,
der Betriebsrat stimmt noch dagegen, was aber noch
nie vorgekommen ist. Hab ich gesagt, okay, klingt logisch.
Ja, und
auf dem Weg raus hab ich
noch die
Klausenunterlagen von einem Kollege von
mir, meinem,
also quasi meinem damals
zukünftigen Chef in die Hand gedrückt.
Hast du in Würzburg verbrannte
Erde hinterlassen? Nee, ich hab einfach gesagt,
ähm, ich hab mich anderweitig
entschieden. Keine verbran... Wie stellt man sich
das vor? Ich hab bestimmt nicht gesagt,
alle ihr Kackspasten, ich geh nicht zu euch,
hier, fickt euch.
Warum sollte ich das machen? Ich hätte, ich fand
die eigentlich ganz gut und hätte da auch angefangen.
Ich hab einfach nur gesagt, ich hab mich
anderweitig
entschieden und, ähm, hab's denen sogar
noch eine gute Bewertung auf
Kununu
geschrieben für das Bewerbungsverfahren.
Also da können die sich echt nicht beschweren.
Ich hab keine verbrannte Erde hinterlassen.
So, ich hab noch nicht mal bei meinem alten
Arbeitgeber verbrannte Erde in dem Sinn
hinterlassen.
So, und
dann ging das alles recht
schnell. Kollege von mir
haben die sogar auch genommen.
Passte wunderbar und
da bin ich mit dem quasi dann letztendlich
letztes Jahr im April
dahin gewechselt zur Versicherung
in Frankfurt und
die ist, die ist nur 800 Meter Luftlinie
vom alten Arbeitgeber weg.
Ich geh teilweise mit alten Kollegen immer noch Mittagessen.
Mit denen, wo man
sich gut verstanden hat.
Joah.
Nur das Bewerbungsverfahren zu bewerten
ist aber Code für Kackladen. Warum?
Was soll ich denn
sonst bewerten, wenn ich nie dort gearbeitet habe?
Ja, das hab ich gelesen.
Das ist halt komplett für den Arsch.
Das hab ich gelesen hier.
Ja, und seit dem April hab ich da angefangen.
Da bin ich jetzt fast, fast,
runden wir mal auf fast ein Jahr, bin ich
jetzt schon da.
Ja, und was mir beim neuen Laden
auf den Keks geht,
ist tatsächlich die super hohe Bürokratie.
Dafür find ich's ansonsten ganz nice.
Auch was die Projekte
angeht und die Leute auch und so.
Das ist zumindest ein großer Unterschied,
muss ich mal sagen, zwischen dem
meinem neuen Arbeitgeber und dem alten Arbeitgeber ist.
Die im Durchschnitt deutlich
bessere Ausbildung der Führungskräfte.
Da ist es nämlich,
erst mal beim alten Laden war das so,
dass die
gefühlt random Leute
gepickt haben, um beispielsweise Teamleiter
zu werden, so nach dem Motto. Ah ja, wir hier,
wir suchen jemanden. Ah ja, du hier, hast du Bock?
Egal, ob die sich eignen, ob die das hinkriegen,
nix, ja, unvorbereitet. Ich hab's sogar
schon erlebt, dass Leute nach einem halben Jahr gesagt haben,
mach ich nicht mehr. Im neuen Laden ist das
deutlich besser geregelt. Ja, da
kann man sagen, ey, das ist was,
ich weiß selbst noch nicht, ob ich das machen
will, ähm, es
interessiert mich aber, da kannst du ein paar Kurse belegen,
da kannst du schon mal üben, so, wie ist es Chef zu sein
und sowas. Eigentlich gut gemacht. Ich meine, ihr kennt
mich, ich hab null Ambitionen da drauf, ich werde
das nie freiwillig machen.
Und
ich mach da einen Bogen drum. Aber das ist wirklich
besser. Also das merkt man auch, dass
im Durchschnitt die Führungskräfte in dem neuen Laden
deutlich, so soll man sagen,
ja, mehr Plan
haben von ihrer
Rolle als Führungskraft als im alten.
Und die sagen auch, und das finde ich ganz gut,
so nach dem Motto, ey,
ähm, wir haben noch, wir wissen,
dass wir keine Ahnung haben von der Technik,
deswegen
orientieren wir uns an dem, was die
Leute uns empfehlen. So, das finde ich ja schon mal eine
prinzipielle gute Einstellung, weil es ist
einfach so, dass selten gute
Techniker gute Manager sind und selten gute
Manager gute Techniker sind.
Und ich denke auch, ich bin niemand, der sagt, es ist
komplett useless, kann man alles selbst
besser machen. Wenn man ein paar gute
Manager hat, sei es jetzt Projekt,
Leiter oder eben direkte Chefs,
die verstehen, was sie
machen, kann das durchaus zur
Arbeitserleichterung und zum Klären
von Problemen oder zum nicht
erst Auftreten von Problemen beitragen.
Aber wo es halt problematisch
wird, ist, wenn die dann auch
noch der Meinung sind, sie wissen über alles super Bescheid,
obwohl sie gar nicht Bescheid wissen.
Und das ist dann nicht so. Also, ich hab's jetzt
schon öfters erlebt, dass mein Chef mich mal
angeschrieben hat in Teams und gesagt hat, hier,
äh, Max, das und das Thema,
äh,
die wollen da was von mir wissen,
ich hab keine Ahnung, kannst du mir das mal erklären,
so? Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja. Und jetzt bin
ich da, also im Prinzip gibt's auch nicht so viel zu
erzählen drüber.
Wer auch immer das gefragt hat,
ich hab's, äh, ja,
Louis, viel, viel
mehr Spannendes gibt's da nicht. Willst du, willst du noch
irgendwas Spezielles wissen? Das war's
eigentlich. Ja, das sind irgendwelche
Sales-Leute, die sinnlos Sachen verkaufen.
Nee. Warum
soll ich das freiwillig machen?
Also, mich hat keiner gezwungen, was
zu, äh, zu schreiben. Die haben nur gefragt,
nachdem ich abgesagt habe,
nachdem ich, wie gesagt, nachdem ich abgesagt hab,
haben die gefragt, ob ich, äh, den
Bewerbungsprozess raten
könnte. Und ich sagte, ja, klar, mach ich.
Bin ich jetzt nichts Verwerfliches
dran.
Welche Programmiersprache kannst du mir empfehlen, um
Backend zu programmieren? Backend für was?
Web-Anwendung?
Ich persönlich mag, äh, .NET.
ASP.NET Core als Framework.
Kannst du aber auch genauso
mit Go machen.
Je nachdem, was du machen willst in dem Backend,
eignet sich vielleicht die ein oder andere
Technologie mehr oder weniger.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was du machen willst.
Am besten
ist in der Regel tatsächlich das, was du kannst.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Also, mein Lieblingsframework
und Runtime und Programmiersprache
ist halt einfach
.NET und C-Sharp.
Also, wenn ich nicht ein spezielles,
muss ich sagen, so spezielle Anforderungen
hab, so wie ich brauch was, wo es nur eine Library
in Rust gibt oder nur in Go gibt oder sowas,
wie beispielsweise letztens mit
WebRTC, dann mach ich das
eigentlich immer in .NET.
Ich will nicht wieder mit C++
Rant anfangen, hab ich ja in den letzten zwei Wochen
gemacht, weil ich so blöd
war und mir ein C++
Talk angeguckt hab über
undefined behavior.
Und wo ich mich ernsthaft
gefragt hab, warum zum Teufel ist eine
Wildschleife undefined behavior?
Das gibt's auch nur in C++.
Stellt euch mal vor.
While true ist undefined behavior
in C++. Warum? Man versteht
die Welt halt nicht.
Ja, also zu ASP.NET Core
gibt es gute Tutorials und auch
einige Channels, die sich mit .NET beschäftigen.
Go auch.
Oh ja, sollte ich
mal unbedingt, ich weiß nicht, ich bin sehr unmotiviert
gerade da weiter zu machen.
Aber muss man als
Systemintegrator programmieren?
Kommt drauf an, ob du da Bock drauf hast
oder nicht. Wenn du da keinen Bock drauf hast,
kannst du sicherlich dir
Bereiche suchen, wo du das
nicht machen musst. Ich würde sogar sagen,
im überwiegenden Teil so der
klassischen FISI-Bereiche, wo man dann
landet, braucht man das eher
weniger. Wobei man zumindest so ein
bisschen Überblick über
simple Sachen wie irgendwelche Bash-Skript
Automatisierungs-Sachen schon haben sollte.
Aber wenn einen das persönlich
interessiert und man da Bock drauf
hat, findet man auch genug Bereiche, wo
sich das gut
integriert, wenn man programmieren kann
als Systemintegrator.
Und nachdem ich hauptsächlich im Cloud
Infrastruktur
Umfeld zu Gange
bin, dort viel mit Terraform
hantiert wird und generell auch
die ein oder anderen Google
APIs angesprochen werden müssen,
finde ich es nice, dass ich ein bisschen
programmieren kann. Und nachdem ich gerne
programmier, bastle ich auch die ein
oder anderen internen Tools bei uns.
Wie zum Beispiel
das jetzt für die
Berufsbereitschaft,
wo man sich ein- und ausstechen kann.
Also,
man findet immer was.
Ich habe das auch bei mir in die Ziele reinschreiben lassen.
Ich hatte letztens mit meinem Chef erst einen Termin.
Ja. Ich habe reinschreiben
lassen, Automatisierung
Schrägstrich DevOps.
Das ist auch einfach ein Begriff, so ein Buzzword,
das liest sich unglaublich gut.
Und so blöd es klingt,
ist es auch,
ist es auch. Aber so blöd es klingt,
die hohe Kunst
ist es,
was Cooles zu machen
in einem Tag und die restlichen drei
Tage, ich meine, ich mache das nicht so,
aber die hohe Kunst
wäre, ein Tag was richtig
Cooles zu machen und es dann drei Tage
überall breit zu treten. Damit kommt
man leider weiter, als
vier Tage
was Cooles machen.
Man muss es jetzt ja nicht so
total übertreiben, aber ab und zu mal
was Geiles machen und es aber auch
möglichst breit treten, dass man was Geiles
gemacht hat, bringt einen einfach
mehr, als stumm vor sich hin
nur geile Sachen zu machen.
Rust ist super hyped. Ja.
Will ein Backend für eine Webseite
mit Datenbankanbindung programmieren. Das kannst du
in nahezu jeder Programmiersprache
machen. Das kannst du in JavaScript mit Node
machen. Das kannst du in .NET
C-Sharp, ASP.NET Core machen.
Das kannst du in Go machen. Das
kannst du in Python machen. Das kannst du in Ruby
machen. Ruby. Kannst du Ruby on
Rails machen. Das kannst du
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
sogar in C++ machen.
Wenn man das wirklich will.
Also das kannst du
eigentlich überall machen. Das heißt, da würde ich
tatsächlich bevorzugen, wenn du eine
Programmiersprache kennst.
Ja, das was er hier schreibt,
dann nimm doch das. Kennst du schon
irgendwas? Also
Description. Hat hier schon jemand was
eingetippt hier?
No Pass.
Ja, Bane, kannst du schon irgendwas
machen.
Also, wenn du eine Programmiersprache
nimmst, dann nimm die.
Ich krieg hier wieder Zeug empfohlen.
Was ist mit den Shorts los, Alter?
Es ist so dumm, dass ich meine
Watch-History verloren habe auf YouTube.
Aber so langsam, aber so langsam,
aber sicher, immerhin
bekommt man so halbwegs so grob
wieder was rein.
Kann Python und Flask. Da kannst
du doch schon alles. Du brauchst
doch nicht mal Django. Flask, wenn du
willst.
Ich weiß nicht, was ein guter Datenbank
ORM ist.
Für Python kenn ich mich nicht gut genug
damit aus. Was gibt's denn da?
Alchemie oder wie das heißt, gibt es
doch für Python, oder? Wie heißt das?
SQL
Alchemie oder sowas?
Gab's früher. Ich hab mich damit
nie groß beschäftigt.
Weiß nicht, was man in Python gerne verwendet.
Aber du kannst doch eigentlich schon alles, was du brauchst.
Python, Flask fürs Backend
und dann... Ups, das wollte ich jetzt nicht
wirklich anklingen.
Was hab ich da angeklickt?
Äh, Chainlow, was postest du für
Dinger? Was soll das sein?
Ach ja, gut, wenn du eine neue Programmiersprache
lernen willst,
Go ist ganz nice
zu kennen. Ich persönlich
mag .NET und C-Sharp
am liebsten.
Ich kann die nicht wegvoten, weil ich nicht eingeloggt
bin. Das stimmt.
Ja, also ich persönlich wäre ja auch für C-Sharp.
Und mit den Starter,
mit den eingebauten Starter
Beispiel, ne oder wie heißt das?
Mit diesen Templates, die da mittlerweile
eingebaut sind, wo du einfach sagen kannst
.NET New Web API
oder sowas. Oder .NET New Web.
Kriegst auch ein Minimalprojekt und siehst gleich, wie's
funktioniert.
Das Schöne bei .NET ist,
was du, wo du echt einen Vorteil hast,
das ist alles integriert. Also,
du installierst dir .NET,
sagst .NET
New Web zum Beispiel
und du hast halt alles mit dabei, ja.
Du hast ein Beispiel für APIs und du hast schon
gleich mit Entity Framework Core
kannst du ordentlich deine Datenbank
ansprechen.
Es gibt Module für alle
Datenbanken so dieser Welt,
unter anderem auch für SQLite, was wunderbar ist,
damit anzufangen.
Das einzig Blöde an .NET
ist, dass es Microsoft Shit ist, aber
ich habe den Eindruck, .NET hat am
wenigsten Probleme damit, Microsoft Shit zu sein.
Was? Habe auch
gehört, dass HTTPS Frameworks
auf Python auslaufen kann.
Was?
Der Satz ergibt keinen Sinn.
Faxende in Bayern!
Oh, was machen die denn jetzt?
Bayerns Digitalminister hat eine
Vision. Leute, das Ende
des Faxgerätes nennt man in Deutschland
Vision. Man würde eigentlich
erwarten, aber es ist eigentlich
umgedreht. Man wundert sich immer, dass Faxe
da sind, ja? Aber es ist eine
Vision, dass
das Faxe...
Ja, das ist wirklich echt.
Deutschland und Digitalisierung.
Oh Mann. Das sind die
Alternativen.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was E-Akte sein soll.
Wahrscheinlich wieder eine tolle Benahmung
von irgendeinem IT-Projekt
unserer Regierung.
Haben eigentlich mittlerweile alle
Leute 50 Mbit?
Das, was wir 2018
schon haben sollten?
Gibt's eigentlich 50 Mbit für alle
mittlerweile? Was macht der
Unraid-Server? Der unrated.
Kann ich C-Sharp auch auf Visual Studio Code verwenden?
Ja, kannst du, ist aber nicht so schön.
Nimm Visual Studio,
das ist kostenlos für Windows.
Oder ansonsten Rider. Aber
Rider kannst du die Trial ausprobieren, weil
das kostet.
Oh Leute, ich hab übelst
Hunger!
Ich geh sowas essen, ey. War heute ein bisschen
kürzer, ich musste heute länger rennen.
Ich war heute fast über
eine Stunde, über Stunde 10 oder so
unterwegs, weil die Schranke war
zu und die Ampel war rot.
War richtig kacke. Bin auch vorwärts gekommen
zwischenzeitlich. Ich geh jetzt was
futtern. Nudeln mit Lachs
selbstverständlich.
Was sonst?
Sonntagmorgen?
Chicken.
Nee, Chicken gibt's nicht heute.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Weil es sonntags immer Nudeln mit Lachs gibt.
Alternativ Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
Lachsenjoyer.
Leute, wir hören uns nachher. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.